it's my mission to show how much more
consensus there is than controversy more
vegetables more Whole Foods less added
sugar and less refined grain those are
four of the biggest problems with the
U.S diet if you put all those together
they are all well aligned with a
plant-based diet
episode is brought to you by timeline
nutrition which is this new skin health
line of products check it out and get 10
off your first order
[Music]
it is a pleasure and an honor to meet
you and to have you here I mean you are
one of the world's Premier leading
nutrition scientists focused on studying
what to consume and what to avoid for
Optimal Health there's so much nutrition
science out there uh and many of these
studies trickle down or find their way
into mainstream media and click bait
titles and reductionist sort of briefs
on what these studies said or perhaps
didn't say that creates a lot of
confusion in the public hence the
nutrition Wars on social media Etc but
you know why do we find ourselves in
that situation and and you know what are
you doing in terms of the studies that
you're creating to try to rectify that
perception yeah I think you've captured
it really well and it's it's my after
being in this field for 30 years it's my
mission to show how much more consensus
there is than controversy uh and and the
deal there is as you said you could find
a study that has almost any position you
want out of the context of all the
literature that there is
so especially I'm sure the world of
social media has really exacerbated all
this what what gets the click bait going
here it's everything you knew for 50
years is wrong right the contrarian
point of view that's what you want to
click on or Jelly Beans really are good
for you or ice cream which is
preposterous which actually was an
Atlantic headline just in the last month
oh yeah yeah I remember that yeah that
just came out I mean that who wants to
click on something that says you should
eat more vegetables really oh my God I
better click oh wait I've heard that 50
times and I don't really like vegetables
or something along those lines so that
the challenge is when you do food food
is is a pain in the butt to study it's
really complicated it's cultural there's
all kinds of preferences involved
and pill studies are easier so
supplement studies are like medical
design studies there's a placebo and an
active what's the placebo to food
there isn't one right and so for me that
the challenge is how generalizable can
you make this that it's real food
and how rigorous can you make it that
it's science because a lot of stuff in
nutrition is matching let's make sure
everything is matched
well if everything is matched then it's
not food anymore so it's sort of this
balance of generalizability and rigor
that floats my boat so
yeah I've been approaching it uh in my
studies trying to make it practical
involve other disciplines that's been
really fun for me too so I have a PhD in
nutrition science
but there's really a lot of Economics
psychology here taste pleasure joy and
when you put them all together to be
perfectly honest Michael pollen really
nailed it eat food not too much mostly
plants right and he gets away with so
much I'm so jealous like he writes that
book and it's very engaging
and I really do think he nailed it but
he did come up with indefensive food
after that which is 27 chapters or so of
here's what I really meant and as he
gets into it and he starts picking apart
what's food what's mostly what's not too
much that all requires some definition
and then people get embroiled in
controversy again when it it doesn't
need to be so I which I shouldn't even
have a job really I should be out of a
job if people would just eat food right
I wouldn't have but it is complicated
and people are messy so that's the
problem right even in the most
well-designed trial
um and you can come up with you know you
can run a trial and control it to the
best of your you know ability Etc uh and
come up with some pretty Ironclad
results as a result of that and yet
because you can't create the perfect
scenario you're always open to criticism
for people who refuse to believe that
this is the case right because people
are involved because there are always
going to be variables outside of your
control or whatever
um you know kind of definitions you
apply to your study about term or you
know portion size or whatever somebody
will say well you didn't do this or you
should have done it this way and if you
had it would have been different hence
we can't read anything reasonable into
this yeah and so my Approach and all my
so I design a study and I write it up
and I don't do any animal model studies
but mechanistic people do and they
control everything and they can chop a
head off and grind up a spleen or a
liver and look at some very mechanistic
things which that's not what I do but I
sometimes cite that and you've got
observational epidemiology
where you're tracking people for 40
years and the knee-jerk reaction is
Association not causation and my
immediate reaction is oh my God that is
so cool they know who ended up in the
hospital with cancer or heart disease I
never had that option in my job I
wouldn't get promoted if I said cool
I've started this study and in 30 years
I'll report can I just keep my job for
30 years until they're done
so I do little studies of risk factors
so I recruit live human beings feed them
real food and try to lower their
cholesterol blood pressure weight or
something cool and new like
trimethylamine oxide
and then I say okay I change the risk
factor that should lead to preventing a
disease but I honestly don't know
because something else might have
happened in the meantime and as you were
just saying oh what if I double the dose
what if it was in half what if it was
that instead of something else so as
soon as I report one of my randomized
controlled trials which is sort of the
gold standard of nutrition research
instant feedback is yeah but what if you
change that one parameter and I say crap
you're right that that's totally
plausible but I didn't do that study I
did the one I did in it the randomized
controlled trials are very narrow
questions as opposed to
is meat bad for me is soy good for me
yeah those are unanswerable questions
they have to be much more specific yeah
in order to answer that how are you
defining good or bad right and what
factors or things are you looking at to
make that determination and one of the
things that you've done kind of as an
innovator is go beyond the conventional
approaches when it comes to weight loss
and you know sort of disease disease
prevention to look at things like
um metabolic health and tmao as you said
inflammatory markers uh that we're now
learning are perhaps more informative in
terms of telling us what's going on in
our bodies and how we're responding to
the foods that we're eating yep and it's
exciting and and fun to explore these
new areas and let's just start with
inflammatory markers for one so if you
put together all the traditional risk
factors that you go to see when you get
your doc looking at you your lipid
profile your glucose your blood pressure
your weight you put all that into a
mathematical model and they say yeah
this explains like 50 percent of heart
disease or diabetes or cancer and 50 is
unexplained what could it be
ah immune function inflammation insulin
resistance in in my scientific World
those are all really hot topics right
now the microbiome what's happening in
your microbiome ah maybe that's the
other 50 percent this is super exciting
let's engage in this
none of those have progressed to the
point where they're easy clinical
measures have you been to your doctor
and gotten your immune function number
your inflammatory status
your microbiome your microbiome number
no because there's a thousand species of
microbes and in my world of inflammation
here's here's my quick story on this I
was very excited to get into this and I
had a colleague in this area and we've
got three different grants from the NIH
and we focused on mcp1
intracellular soluble adhesion molecule
one tnf alpha something else so these
are the four
if you look at these four inflammatory
markers
nobody agrees on all of them but at
least every reviewer will like one of
these and I said four it seems like a
lot so we had these measured and then I
went for another study and said this is
we have a cool new deal for you you can
get 50 of them for a hundred bucks and I
said wow 50.
then so we have a new platform called o
link you can get 90 for the same amount
as you were getting 50. said I I think
that sounds good and they said actually
we have nine different platforms that
have 90 markers so you could get this
many and I said
I don't think I want nine platforms with
90 markers I want a number I want an
inflammation number and the field isn't
there yet so we all kind of agree this
chronically elevated inflammation that's
not rheumatoid arthritis not a very
acute condition uh where you're being
treated but just chronically moderately
elevated that's probably is underlying a
lot of diet related chronic disease
we can't help you clinically we don't
have a number and and it makes it really
hard for me to do a study on that topic
and be very precise this dose this
duration this outcome at the end
it is just too complicated and the
science is only now emerging in that
field and like so many of the the you
know things that you're looking at
um the complexity extends so much
further beyond what the general public
is aware hence I know you're working on
a book and you were telling me last
night that your operating title that was
rejected by the publisher is it depends
right like it's not a satisfying phrase
like it but it does depend there are so
many things uh upon which these outcomes
Depend and it just is impossible to you
know refine that down to a paragraph or
a sentence that's going to be uh you
know an operative directive for the
average person to just say just tell me
what to eat just do I do what do I do
come on you know it depends but that's
the truth and that's science and it and
I think if you if you narrow that down
to a couple of things like what was the
food what was the comparator what did
they eat it with who was the person I
think as a community the the folks
interested in nutrition reading this
could be more effectively critical if
they just got a couple of those basics
down so one of my experiences back in my
PhD in the early 90s was two articles
that came out in in just one year and
one said oat bran is great for you and
the other one said oat bran doesn't work
and it looked like those are Polar
Opposites
all he had to do was look very closely
and see the one where it worked was
older men with high cholesterol the oat
bran lowered their cholesterol the other
one was college students with normal
cholesterol and it didn't go lower than
normal it was already normal the
headline made it seem like they were
opposite and really it would have been
easy to say if you don't have elevated
cholesterol then this oat bran probably
isn't going to lower it below normal but
if you do have elevated cholesterol and
you want to avoid a drug you might want
to try this oat bran
that's all you'd have to say or you
could make it controversial the
nutrition scientists never agree
right I feel like I mean I'm all for
free speech but I feel like there needs
to be some kind of counsel for the
responsibility of of uh medical and
nutritional uh journalism in this regard
because you know those those are simple
titles to articles and who knows what
those articles actually said in whatever
uh Publications they were in but they
have such a huge impact on the average
person who doesn't have who's never
going to go to PubMed and may not even
read that entire magazine article or
newspaper article yeah and there are a
couple Publications out there that are
Center for Science and public interest
puts out a health action newsletter the
Berkeley Wellness letter is really good
your podcast is really good Simon Hills
podcast is really good it's sort of like
there was a new study and in the context
of the rest
it made a little difference but there
was a huge context that it goes in and
so it doesn't overturn everything we
knew for the last 50 years right it adds
another dimension to this and that's
interesting and
usually it doesn't overturn what you
knew yesterday right which is like again
that goes to the that that thing inside
of us that wants that hot take that
contrarian yeah you know reductionist
perspective and it's disappointing when
it doesn't pan out that way but you know
the truth hopefully you know surfaces to
the top over time
um and on that topic let's let's talk
about a few of your you know better
known studies
um
I think the study that you're probably
initially became very well known for was
this A to Z study where you paired a
variety of
I guess they're called fad diets are
they fat you know fat whatever
protocols at the time so this was like
2007 2000 in 2007. yeah so walk me
through
um how you came up with this idea and
how you designed this study and and what
you discovered yeah it was pretty fun so
and actually this goes way back before
then I applied originally to the USDA
for some funding and this is sort of
just in the early 2000s when Atkins uh
had been revived the Atkins book came
out in the seven 1970s and was dismissed
and all of a sudden it was revived and
there was a huge amount of interest in
it and the Zone was coming out then and
your swimmer actually did you know Barry
Sears well I have a story about that
actually so I I graduated Stanford in
89.
um
and the coach skip Kenny was well known
for getting really excited about one
thing or another from time to time and
he would find these people and bring
them in and have that person talk to us
whether it was a mindset coach or some
new idea that he thought would be
helpful and I remember a couple years
after I graduated I came back for an
alumni weekend it must have been 91 92
or something like that and I was at a
tailgate party before the football game
with a bunch of the swimmers the younger
guys and they're like man skip brought
this guy very very Sears in to talk to
us because skip was all about the Zone
diet the coach and he was he was trying
to get the whole team on board and he
had I think he hired Barry Sears who
like worked with the team to try to get
these guys on the program and and I
think in retrospect if memory serves me
later on Barry Sears sort of publicly
took credit for some some of the
successes of these athletes at the
Olympics but I will tell you as somebody
who knows these athletes personally and
talk to them about this they were like
yeah he came in he wanted us to do this
30 40 whatever it was yeah like we
didn't no way they're burning like you
know they're they're so hungry they're
eating so many calories none of them
actually did it so Barry Sears may have
claimed that he got everybody on board
with this diet but they weren't actually
practicing it in real life and so they
were kind of you know dismissive of him
irregardless of whether his ideas were
correct or good or or what have you and
I think that speaks to a larger issue
that you come across which is the real
world you know adherence versus like oh
we designed this study and these people
did this well did they really and what
did they do afterwards and you know
what's actually real here yeah so it's a
great story for that but I will add one
comment as I remember at that time said
Stanford swimmers are winning all kinds
of metal since they went on this diet
and somebody said what happened didn't
they win all kinds of medals before the
diet too yes yeah so like did that
trajectory change uh no so again context
but for for my interest was there were
these New York Times best-selling books
and uh here's a little inside baseball
is if you follow nutrition there's
something called the acceptable
macronutrient distribution range it's a
marble mouthful of amdr and the Atkins
diet is outside of that and the ornish
diet is outside of that and the Zone
diet is barely in it and so this is like
wait
there's a whole bunch of popular diets
out there outside the acceptable
macronutrient distribution range what do
we think of these they're New York Times
bestsellers
and so my idea was yeah why don't we do
this and it was kind of interesting some
of the pushback I got
from reviewers so it's like this is a
popular diet I mean why would you study
that if it is a fad diet it'll be out of
fashion by the time you have your
results so there's no reason to study a
fad diet it's like no no some of these
books have been around for a really long
time
somebody should study the books say okay
so are you going to match the protein
and you're going to match this and you
know as part of our scientific rigor
there's there's things to match and not
and my idea was they're selling the
books Let's just have them read the book
let's see what happens
and then there's another group saying
okay now once they've read the book
they'll have to follow exactly what the
book said and said I don't think so I
don't think a nutritionist comes with a
book when you buy it at the bookstore
they read it and then you have to see
what they do
so the fun of this study was it was
designed very intentionally
so that for the first eight weeks of the
one year study a dietitian would come in
and and I'm exaggerating but basically
read the book out loud to you 1 8 of the
book each time for eight weeks
to make sure they had at least read it
because what we did find here's a fun
anecdote we put people on the Atkins
diet again which was very popular at the
time and some of them would show up to
these classes and say half my office
says they're on the Atkins diet but I
have read it and they are not
they say that they they obviously don't
understand it I have read the book
and these people say they're on and they
got like one concept out of the book
not having read it and they say they're
on it so
part of the rigor here was make sure
they've read the book
and then after eight weeks what we told
him very intentionally was we're not
going to help you anymore if you want
moral support or social support we'll
help you if you call us but if you have
questions about adherence to the diet
we're not going to help you you read it
we're gonna see what happens and one of
the funniest uh stories from this for me
was I pretty sure it was an email from
Barry Sears toward the end of this at
the end of the study
the Atkins group did a little better at
six months from six months to 12 months
the weight was coming on faster than the
other group so I I suspect if we carried
it out to two years they all would have
been the same
the actual finding of the study was the
only two diets that were different from
one another
or Atkinson's own now this is a little
bit of a head scratcher because by
picking Atkins is the lowest carb zone
is the second lowest carb learn which
was sort of a health professional's
approach and ornish which was the
highest carb it was very intentionally a
range of low fat to low carb extremes
so low fat or low carb were different it
should have been the two extremes that
were different ornish and Atkins
it wasn't the only two that were
statistically different were Atkins and
Zone those were the two low carb diets
Zone
lost the least
and Atkins lost the most so it's not
really
an advertisement for low carb
my personal opinion was the Zone
instructions were really hard to follow
and Atkins was quite easy don't eat
carbs right so it's an adherence and
kind of real world human problem not
um not so much an issue it it was
specifically and intentionally designed
not to really pit these three different
diets against each other but to see how
actually people behave in the real world
when they take in information how it
works and so Barry's interpretation of
this when they tried to follow Atkins
and fell short they were pretty close to
Zone
so he said my diet wins and I said wait
wait if you want to be on the Zone diet
read the Atkins yes basically exactly
and I have a flip side to that which is
Dean ornish was quite upset said well I
don't you know you didn't get them to
follow my diet and I said Dean we bought
them the book and we gave them a
nutritionist and they read it if you
looked so we did extensive dietary
assessment on this at Baseline three
months six months and 12. and if you
looked at 12 months the ornish diet is
10 fat they were at 30 percent fat
not ten if you were they claiming they
were still on it well
they were assigned to it I mean the way
I wrote the paper up was they were
assigned to this is and this is what
they did and I sort of I have a chart of
what the um Amer the guidelines of the
American Heart Association and dietary
guidelines for Americans are in shooting
for ornish
they fell into the dietary guidelines in
shooting for Atkins they kind of fell
into zone so it's almost like it was a
Zone versus dietary guidelines study
according to how they followed it
but no they got assigned to these four
different books and so as you started
this conversation you said it's more
about adherence and what real people can
do
they couldn't do the extreme diets they
could not do ornish and they could not
do Atkins and so that is how we wrote
this study we assigned them to this we
got them the book and they read it
here's what happened they pretty much
lost the same amount of weight at the
end except for Atkins and Zone and our
more stunning conclusion was it was like
on average a couple pounds difference
between them at the end
but what's super cool is how variable
they were within each group within each
four of each of the four diet groups
somebody lost 50 pounds and somebody
gained 10 or 15 and those were not
outliers everything
in between so my Epiphany from this
study was
people getting the exact same advice
can have wildly variable results ah that
is humanly personally
fascinating why are we so complicated
but it was reading a book it seemed to
me a very
practical public health approach to this
question of weight loss
so extrapolating from that big picture
humans are complicated there are all
kinds of mechanisms at play that that
must be accounting for this wide variety
of results with weight gain and weight
loss and and other sort of uh uh you
know results that you were seeing and
then also the very sticky problem of
like how humans behave you know like
just because you read a book or this
says do this and it is sometimes I would
imagine you see people who who say no
I'm doing it exactly like they think
they're doing it exactly right yes but
in reality they're not and then other
people who are like yeah I know I'm kind
of veering off here and there but you
know I'm trying to make it sustainable
like I I guess what I'm getting at is
different levels of self-awareness
around adherence even within that
population of people right yeah they do
there are people who think they're doing
it and you follow up with them and say
this is one of the things we told you
not to eat oh I didn't understand that I
thought it was the other way
but two of my favorite words in my field
that you're kind of getting at is
Effectiveness and efficacy
and so in some of the studies that you
do some of the some of the scientists
will publish two things one is the
intention to treat and one is per
protocol is one of the ways to frame it
an intention to treat is here's what
everybody did
what if you had somebody that you
assigned to ornish and in the middle
they hated it and they went Atkins and
you know they did because you look at
what they're eating you have to include
them in the results and you have to keep
them in the ornish group so that's
intention to treat where there's a lot
of
there's a lot of variability because of
that protocol is we only took the people
who did it right
and that's usually a much smaller subset
of the population and it's a quite
relevant question so if you followed it
as designed this would have been the
result
so it's nice to know the efficacy
results of if you did it this would
happen and also see yeah but when you
randomly assign people most people don't
do it both of those
our important perspective has to be
infuriating for you I mean as as
fascinating and as curious as that is
it's got to be frustrating but it's less
frustrating than doing a rat study
keeping them in a cage feeding them
exactly what you wanted and Reporting
and flipping the news that this thing
happened and seeing yeah but humans
don't do that and so this isn't helping
humans because we have to do this and
understand
someone got divorced someone got in a
car accident someone lost their job life
happened to them and this is what
happens in Life or more realistically
some of those very restrictive diets are
good short term
but personally I I really don't like the
word diet in terms of I went on a diet
that I'm going to go off as soon as I
get what I need out of it
diet should be a noun this is this is my
diet I eat this way I'm going to eat
this way for the rest of my life
and so when you see these really
restrictive diets
they have short-term results
but that's because the practicality you
can do restrictive things for a few
weeks or a month but you can't do them
long term and when you go back to the
old diet all the things that were
plaguing you before come back and it's
not effective right
if you're a Gen X dude like me then skin
care can feel a little indulgent but I
actually wish that I didn't wait until
my 50s to take care of my skin a little
bit better because hey it's our largest
organ it's essential to health and it's
our first line of defense against
environmental aggressors the fact is as
we age our mitochondria generate less
energy so anything that you can do to
boost these little power plants is
absolutely huge timelines worked it out
in their nutrition products and now they
figured it out with skin care cracking
the code with this new product called
mitopure which is a patented version of
a postbiotic that they've discovered
helps rejuvenate mitochondria and
promotes healthy skin it's backed by 15
years of clinical research they've got
three products the day cream the night
cream and the serum I've been testing
them and using them I'm really enjoying
it I do think my skin looks better and
it looks more refreshed it feels more
refreshed and you should check it out so
to get you started timeline is offering
10 off your first order click the link
in the description below and use the
code Rich Roll to
all right back to the show
taking
uh what you can do with mice because you
can control their environment a little
bit better that becomes more difficult
with people but Christopher there is a
precedent at Stanford around
incarcerating students for the purpose
of science oh yes yes you can lock them
in the basement Infamous stuff zimbardo
did it
yeah you see controversial yes maybe not
maybe maybe not in 2023 okay but yeah
I'm not sure I want to go there but yes
that was a yeah an experiment gone awry
but this idea of of trying to understand
this uh unpredictable variability in
weight loss and weight gain that came
out of the say to Z uh study I gather
that that must have been top of Mind in
trying to uh design this diet fit study
where you're going to look at some
unique uh factors that maybe hadn't been
looked at before at least with rigor in
terms of nutrition and weight loss by
pitting low-fat a low-fat diet against a
low carb diet and looking not just at
weight loss weight gain or some of the
typical biomarkers but by honing in on
insulin resistance and metabolic Health
as well as genotype yeah so the fun at
finishing that A to Z study again was
seeing that variable response and
thinking okay the cool question here is
not which diet is better it's which diet
is better for whom
there must be some pre there aren't
there predisposing factors so instead of
telling the American public or the
global Community here's the best diet
what if there's a factor that
predisposes you to doing better on one
than that doesn't that make a lot of
sense yeah we should go after some of
those and so after we finished A to Z
two things happened one is a group
approached us and said can we look at
your DNA
and there was a signal in the DNA about
a possible genetic predisposition it had
to do with single nuclear polymorphisms
nucleotide polymorphisms
Snips and they had these two genotype
patterns a low carb genotype pattern and
a low-fat genotype pattern and
retrospectively it looked like it would
have worked in A to Z but that's more of
a hypothesis generating approach by
digging into old data and the more
rigorous one would be okay now that we
have these genotype patterns let's
design a new trial and test it
and the idea being that or the
expectation perhaps being that somebody
who has a certain
um
genotype for uh for doing well on a on a
low carb diet is going to fare better
versus the vice versa right and it
should play out if we conduct this study
and pretty easy if you just mismatch
them so have some matched and some
mismatched the other one that came out
right about the time that we were
finishing was a slew of relatively small
short-term studies that focused on this
insulin resistance idea and I found this
super appealing
or just intuitively appealing because
I'm trying to look for what would be
predisposing factors and people with
insulin resistance have a hard time
putting away carbs
and so it doesn't really say it in the
name but every low-fat diet is a high
carb diet I don't know if you want to go
here but protein across many many
different diets
barely budges it's almost always 20
sometimes the reviewers want to make
sure I've matched for protein and
maybe on another day we'll discuss I
don't have to like protein always ends
up about 20 of calories in a if you're
just eating a variety of range of foods
even if you manipulate low carb and low
fat so it's all I wanted to do was do
low carb or low fat and if you're low
fat
which carbs are you eating like you
could be eating lentils and squash and
whole grains or you could be drinking
Coke and you could be having white flour
tortillas and white flour bagels and
donuts
so we said all right let's do this thing
let's only do low carb and low fat and
let's do the genotype thing and the
insulin resistance thing and so for
insulin resistance
uh it's actually a trigger trickier term
than most people might imagine I bet a
lot of your listeners have heard of
insulin resistance
it's not a dichotomous thing it's not
like you are or you aren't there's a
Continuum and there's multiple ways to
measure it and some can be done with a
fasting blood draw which is not as
accurate as this thing called an oral
glucose tolerance test you probably
don't want to get too much into the
weeds but on an empty stomach you have
to drink 75 grams of glucose on an empty
stomach
glucose just flies into your bloodstream
and you can monitor the insulin response
to that and your pancreas freaks out
thinking oh my God I have to put this
glucose away here's how much insulin I'm
going to spit out
to get that put away in cells and if
you're insulin resistance you see this
huge Spike in insulin and
you basically have to kind of cut people
at the median there isn't a number that
says your insulin resistance what you'll
find is some people spit out a lot of
insulin some people spit out very little
and put it all away
but you can Define it and so that's what
we did the whole study was designed to
say okay could genotype pattern or
insulin resistance be part of the
explanation for this huge variability in
what we're seeing and one small feeding
study did this with
20 people
another did it with 24 people
David Ludwig did it with 73 young adults
those sort of three different studies
that had approached this
and all reported the same thing that if
you can identify them ahead of time
being insulin resistant
then they do better on low carb because
they have fewer carbs to put away now
one of the things that's really a
challenge here
is defining low carbon low fat so one of
the ways to do it is just say lower than
yesterday
right now so I've I've often asked
students in my class okay what if I put
index cards in front of each one of you
and I ask you to Define low carb or low
fat is it a gram amount is it a percent
of calories would you all agree on the
same thing
so and this is true to my nature I hope
this is part of what you were
recognizing at the beginning of our talk
I I knew not to give it a number I knew
not to give it a gram amount or a
percent and I did this thing that I
maybe I got away with and I don't know
if your listeners will appreciate this
but this is compellingly what we called
it the limbo titrate quality method
which Probably sounds horrible and let
me try to no it sounds super sexy okay
explain here's how sexy it is we said
okay
we really want you to feel like you are
in a weight loss diet study and you are
expected to change your diet a lot
so whatever carb or fat amount you're
eating depending on which group you're
assigned to you have to go to 20 grams
of carb or 20 grams of fat
most people eat 300 grams a day of carbs
ish so 20 is enormous most people eat
100 grams of fat ish they had to go down
to 20.
but we said we we have some experience
with these really restrictive diets and
we know people can't stick with them so
this is almost like we never
confirmed or affirmed or anything that
they got to 20 and we said you we won't
be kicked out if you don't get there we
just want to psychologically anchor you
so that you know you're in a diet study
and you're removing all the sources of
fat and carb that you can out of your
diet that's the limbo face
we want to do that in eight weeks ish
and some type aaa's got there in two
weeks
and at eight weeks some of the people
weren't quite there so kind of all at
their own speed
we actually didn't even do any diet
assessment at eight weeks the first diet
assessment was at three months because
we said
once you got there as low as you can
stay for a week or two if you can but if
you don't think
you could handle that socially
culturally
if you're hungry
if you can't look Us in the eye and say
yeah doc I could if this works I could
do this for the rest of my life if
you're not there yet add some back do
this titrate thing so add a little
fatter car back
add a little more if you're still not
there add a little more oh is the weight
coming back on and you feel like that
was fun losing weight you want to go
back down again so you can titrate up or
down
but try to look Us in the eye and say I
found this place and this is it man this
is the lowest I could go
and we kind of gave them all an out as
they started the study we said you're
going to have these classes with a bunch
of other folks from your study and
you're going to look across the table
and somebody's going to say wow I'm
nailing this I got this super low and I
feel great and you're gonna
You're Gonna Save that oh man I'm
struggling and I'm not as low as you
part of this study was because of the
genotype thing and the insulin
resistance we're actually betting that
some of you can't go as low as the
others that's part of the study so don't
feel bad don't feel like you're
psychologically not prepared for this
think that you're metabolically or
genotypically
predisposed that's part of the study be
okay with yourself and just help us test
this so they all had an out
they were just supposed to go as low as
they could titrate up
and the quality part was really
important to me and I think is an
important part of the conclusion so he
said and you can't do this with low-fat
brownies or low carb chocolate chip
cookies you you have to go to buy food
you should go to the market farmer's
market and Shop you should try to have a
salad every day both groups low carbon
low fat should have a salad every day
one of the common themes was please get
rid of as much added sugar as you can
please get rid of all the white flour
that you can the refined grain
and after that eat a quality low fat and
a quality low carb and they did so if
you track this out and you read our
paper you'll see all the diet stuff that
they and there were ranges some people
were more successful than others but
they really ate a pretty good quality
low-fat and low carb diet and at the end
drum roll
after a year
Not only was there no difference between
low carb and low fat which there wasn't
on average they both lost 11 to 12
pounds at the end of a year but the
genotype pattern and the insulin
resistance thing both failed
to be an effect modifier or to predict
as a predictor any right of the
variability which stood in contrast to
these short-term studies where they fed
them food and they did it with 20 people
or 70 people
and so writing up the discussion we have
to say you know our results differ from
those others why would
I actually totally expected this to work
I actually was a little skeptical of the
genotype thing
I totally expected the insulin
resistance thing to work and I looked at
it again and again and again and it
didn't work I thought you know
maybe that's because this low-fat group
that they were worried about that had
high carbs for people who are insulin
resistant they got rid of their added
sugars and they're refined grains
and so maybe those people who in other
maybe that's what they were eating on
some of these other studies and that was
part of the reason for the effect they
saw
that we didn't see that was our
explanation of why don't these two
nutrition studies agree well because not
all low carb and low-fat studies are the
same you can set up a study maybe
subconsciously maybe consciously to make
a kick-ass diet a and a crappy diet B if
you're a diet a proponent sure that
happens all the time kick ass B crappy
diet a if you're a diet B proponent our
incentive here was ah God if everybody
loses 100 pounds we're going to be
famous so let's make both diets the best
we can in fact the health Educators that
we're teaching these Health classes had
to teach both low-fat and low carb
throughout the whole study so that even
if you know one of the health Educators
was more inspiring or motivating in
another both groups were getting that
same person yeah I get it in other words
what you're saying is if you go in with
a bias or you're trying to establish
that your Camp is better than the other
and you're pitting two dietary protocols
against each other the one that you're
in favor of you will Design to be very
clean in Whole Food and kind of the best
version of what that has to offer
whereas the competitor will be the
low-grade version that you know is not
going to do well because it's it's an
uncharitable interpretation of that
right but I guess what I so it's again
like wow we didn't figure out what we
thought we were going to figure out and
where does that leave us and what do we
make of this and what can we extrapolate
from this and what can we not like I
think about
um I would imagine that maybe a Critic
would say uh well
you hear this all the time like well
your low fat wasn't low fat enough like
if it was it was if it was really low
fat you would have gotten the result
that I know that you would have gotten
and conversely you know your your low
carb that wasn't low carb like look at
what they were eating that's not I when
I say low carb I mean this that's not
what you did and then um sort of an
ancillary uh critique could possibly be
well how many genotypes did you test for
right yeah three like how many are there
like you just picked the wrong ones yeah
you pick the right ones you would have
seen what you were expecting to see
there is another genotype paper that's
coming out soon so I know there will be
a delay from the time we have this
conversation to when it comes out but
there'll be another genotype paper that
shows genotype didn't work but again
there's probably a million different
genotype
options here to pick from and so you
pick the one that makes the most sense
another one again this is a Time issue I
just got an email this morning from a
postdoctoral research fellow who went
back to our diet fit study and took the
10 percent of the people who were the
lowest fat and the lowest carb got rid
of the other 90 percent and pitted them
head to head there's really no
difference
so here we are like I don't know 50
minutes into this conversation and you
know I'm trying to sit in the chair of
the listener thinking well all right so
far what have I learned you've got what
to do you've learned to eat a good
quality diet so really what I'm after
here in in doing my studies
is to show that there it's not that
there's disagreement here if you put
this in context and said and see that we
had a good quality low carb and a good
quality low fat
that's better than you're gonna you're
gonna farewell yeah and that's already
it goes also to this adherence and
self-awareness issue which is if you I
would imagine if you pulled you know 100
000 average people and ask them what
they eat they would probably report that
they're eating better than they actually
are right and so we have these arguments
around the margins around low carb low
fat Etc uh when in reality the
low-hanging fruit and the real issue
that we should be looking at is you know
what are the big areas on which there is
just incredible consensus amongst the
scientific community in terms of what we
should be doing and and what we
shouldn't be doing yeah and we just
published a study on that from the
American Heart Association if we can go
there yeah yeah because it's sort of
like start here and if you can do that
then do this so I'll start describing
what the the point of this scientific
advisory was it came out in April of
uh the American Heart Association has
regularly for 50 years updated their
dietary guidelines and the previous most
recent update was 2006 and in 2021 they
did it again didn't honestly change all
that much but they refined a few things
and they spent a ton of time in this
paper looking all the literature that
was available before 2006 and between
2006 and 2021
here's all the data we have on who has a
heart attack myocardial infarction
stroke any kind of cardiovascular
disease here's 10 domains
that cover a heart-healthy diet
and those are sort of individual things
about whole grains and veggies and beans
and salt and saturated fat and they said
here's the things to include or avoid
and then the public said so does what
does that mean should I be vegan or
should I be Mediterranean or should I be
paleo I said ah you know what we should
do another paper on patterns so instead
of individual components how many of
these popular dietary patterns out there
could be consistent with this set of
domains in other words like the overlap
in the Venn diagram between all of these
different perspectives and so I want to
focus on the overlap at first so that 10
patterns we picked were the dashed diet
that's the dietary approaches to stop
hypertension Mediterranean
three types of vegetarians who had Pesca
who had the ovo lacto vegetarian red
vegan sort of a higher fat vegan we also
had a really low-fat vegan diet we had a
low carb a low fat a Paleo and a keto I
hope that was 10 because we had 10
patterns
and we tried to match them up to the 10
domains and we scored them from high to
low and dash and Mediterranean got the
best score and paleo and keto got the
worst score as you were matching these
domains and happy to go into some of
those details if you want but one of my
takeaways that I thought was great was
across all 10. they all set more
vegetables more Whole Foods less added
sugar and less refined grain across all
10. now this could be a trivial response
if those are things we already did those
are four of the biggest problems with
the U.S diet we don't eat many
vegetables we eat a lot of ultra
processed food we had a crap ton of
added sugar and a crap ton of refined
grain
so for me this is a Kumbaya moment oh my
God all the patterns agree on 50 percent
of probably what plagues human health
associated with diet why don't we all
get together and work on that that's no
fun
ah yes it's not as the click bait
doesn't work but we really oh agree on
those and those are all big issues the
one extra one I'd love to add in there
is beans I actually think eating more
beans is probably
the biggest thing Americans could do to
change their diet in a positive way and
there's so many kinds of beans
culturally appropriate lots of
unapologetically delicious dishes with
lentils and chickpeas and kidney beans
and refried beans oh my God but you
wouldn't get the Paleo and keto in there
right because they're they're super low
carb
and beans are full of carbs so if you
after the the four things I mentioned
first that they all agree on the next
ones I would add would be beans next
yeah I mean I like that way of looking
at it like this heat map sort of
um perspective that allows you to
transcend all the labels and the
tribalism and all of that and really
just focus on you know this is I think
you've characterized this as being like
50 of the but it's it's kind of like 90
90 isn't it I mean it's really like if
you do those four things and then maybe
the fifth with the beans like you're on
the five yard line
pretty much right and in a nut so and
another way to appreciate uh to yeah
acknowledge that appreciate it is I do
think there are Arguments for some of
these low carb low-fat high protein
individuals for whom and when at the
margin yeah the margins you've got the
foundation right so there'd be a lot
less bickering if yeah I do all these
things and
huh and I actually prefer avocado to
steel cut oats or something I I prefer
this higher protein to this higher carb
whatever
yeah I think you could hedge your bets
and at that point
sort of biohack your own metabolism and
come up with something that's a little
better for you than the other thing but
can you please fix the first 50 or 90
percent because we all agree on that and
you're doing that wrong right so this
first tier of the heat map less added
sugar less refined grains way more
starchy veg more Whole Foods less Ultra
processed foods and then with the
footnote around beans but then there's a
tear just below this right okay we've
done that now how do we get to the next
level and flip that one little thing you
said starchy veg so the one things they
all agree on is non-starchy that's what
I meant to say sorry about broccoli
cauliflower leafy greens red bell
peppers
um but then then you get to the
the avocado the avocados the nuts the
seeds the olive oil
fruits or we can eat fish or we can eat
eggs like that kind of all falls into
that next tier yeah we've got beans with
leptins oh my God no no please just take
one moment like let's go on a like put a
pin in what we're talking about and just
explain this lectin thing quickly
yeah so well there's there's different
things in plants there's fibrous things
there you know fiber is great for the
microbiome plants are toxic fiber binds
some things and sucks it out of you in
in your feces when it leaves but really
the fiber was awesome for your
microbiome and it came with lots of the
plant foods that generated the fiber had
lots of nutrients there's phytates
there's oxalates there's there's lectins
there's there's a couple things
that are less than a hundred percent
perfect but to avoid those
would mean you'd be avoiding getting all
the fabulous things that come with it
and in my sort of you're talking about
this this core that has a second ring
and my second ring is beans oh my God
reluctance fruits oh my God they have
sugar nuts oh my God they have fat eggs
oh my God they have cholesterol fish oh
my God they have a face
you know at that at that second level
the lectins don't matter the sugar and
fruits is fine it's in the food Matrix
the nuts have unsaturated fat so that
next tier of foods is
pretty good
um but it's at the margin after you deal
that thing in the middle and let's
assume we've now mastered this tier okay
what comes next ah where are we gonna
we're gonna go behind the Velvet Rope
and yeah you know put the cherry on top
of the sundae yeah so to be honest
Americans eat too much wheat they eat
too much grain they even eat too much
whole grain bread
so kind of cracks me up going from uh
white flour to oh I used to buy Wonder
Bread now I buy my local whole wheat
bread or I buy my grocery store whole
wheat bread well if you look some of the
whole wheat grocery breads have 30
ingredients in them so we're like at
this Ultra processed thing where there's
dyes and additives and emulsifiers
there's the whole wheat bread that has
five ingredients that's all you need for
bread right I think you need some flour
and water and yeast and sugar and
what's the last salt a little bit of
sodium
would make the bread
I actually make a kick-ass wheat berry
salad people say what what's a wheat
berry and say that's the grain that you
make the flour out of so instead of
grinding it all to a powder and
consuming it in bread you can soak it
and add all the things that I add to my
wheat berry salad which I'm happy to
elaborate on if you ask me it but I'll
start first with this fun thing about
glycemic index
so glycemic indexes how fast the glucose
from the food you're eating ends up in
your blood
and a shocking thing for people who read
into this and look it up is that white
flower bread and whole wheat bread have
the same glycemic index it's like wait
very high high glycemic index is not
good I I switched from white flour to
whole wheat flour how why wasn't that
better and the reason it wasn't better
is because it was ground to a powder and
most of the digestion was done so the
time it takes you to eat it and absorb
it is really small if you had used the
whole grain which is the wheat berry it
would have taken much longer for your
enzymes to digest it and make the
molecules small enough to absorb so the
wheat berry salad glycemic index is
quite low because it takes a long time
so
you're saying go to the next level of
these concentric rings so grains
so a funny thing that I learned from
doing some studies related to protein
and trying to figure out where our
protein comes from is looking at the
usda's
fabulous website of all the food we
produce and what we eat and under grains
it's said okay grains include oats and
barley and wheat and this other thing
but because Americans uh 90 of the
grains that eat are wheat we're simply
using the value for wheat for this thing
that we're analyzing and I stopped for a
moment I said really
has all these grains out there and 90 of
what Americans eat
is wheat
and most of that is bread right pizza
crust Donuts uh you know some kind of
bread like things so at that next level
I think it's grains so I've actually
I hosted a debate one time between a
Paleo person and a Mediterranean person
in a middle of the road person and I
tried to force them to say what do you
agree on I know you guys disagree on
some things what do you agree on
and the first thing I got them all to
agree on that people didn't expect was
grains even like the vegan person said
uh
yeah if I was going to get rid of
anything next it would be grains because
so much of it is refined even even the
whole grain bread
so I'll pause for a minute there to see
what you thought of that because if it
was go ahead yeah no I mean I would say
that yes of course if you're eating the
whole grain and even better the sprouted
version of the whole grain you're eating
a very nutritious food uh it's difficult
to find the whole grain and even more
difficult to sprout it yourself or find
it in sprouted form so even and because
of the way packaging works very often we
think we're eating whole grains when
we're we're not as to your point right
so this has led to you know a valid
criticism of grains for their high
glycemic uh you know impact and their
the fact that they're sort of devoid of
any nutritional value when they're in
that refined form so there's this
vilification of grains that makes it
very difficult to have the conversation
around the appropriateness or the
nutritional value of the whole grain
such that if you raise that to the Paleo
Community or whatever other you know
kind of dietary tribe they will bristle
at the idea that you that there is a
place for incorporating healthy whole
grains into your daily routine and they
could find data they could pull up a
study that said look what happens to the
people who eat grains and what we really
need is the study that said okay they
had steel cut oats for breakfast and
they had a barley soup and they had
Christopher's Kick-Ass wheat berry salad
for dinner what happened to them that we
don't have that study the grains are
wheat and it's mostly refined and I I
can see why there's some adverse studies
when we sure overdo that and then kind
of Beyond these generalizations that's
when
we get into
uh the charting of of undocumented
terrain with respect to personalizing
your nutrition right which is some of
the kind of emergent work that you're
doing
um which I think is really interesting
and well hopefully in time account for
some of these findings that you've
discovered in your studies where
different people are having you know
different you know responses to these
dietary protocols in a way that you know
to date you've been struggling to
account for yep and we could do some
microbiome stuff if you want or we could
wait till later I want to wait till
later for that because there are a
couple other things I want to I want to
get into I mean there's so many studies
I don't know that we can go through all
of them I mean you did this keto Med
trial in in 2022. you know I guess in in
in a nutshell like without going through
the whole the whole rigmarole of this
like it was kind of the same right like
okay like if you're doing this right
we're getting good results for both of
these communities what do we make of
that what are we supposed to do with
that information quality of food maybe
is of more Paramount importance than how
this macro nutrient breakdown is is
being kind of applied to these two
groups I mean in the wake of that like
again it goes to generalizations and
perhaps this personalized nutrition kind
of piece yeah and keto Med we're really
hanging on everything we talked about so
far so I'm very frustrated with keto
this idea that no beans no fruits no
grains that's just contrary to every
Public Health diet recommendation across
a planet
no refined grain no added sugars that's
also consistent with Keto
and all the rest so we set up these two
diets to be compared to one another
where both groups ate as many vegetables
as they could
and absence of added sugar and refined
grain
so those are matched this is sort of
this this the fun for me in designing a
study is what do you match and what
don't you match to make it realistic so
those were matched but opposites on
grains beans and fruits so Mediterranean
yes encouraging all those keto no don't
have any of those and my hypothesis was
if you get rid of the dam added sugar
and refined grain that is 90 of the
battle and that's pretty much what
happened in the study and so without
going into all the details if you if you
could follow those first three pieces of
the advice
yes vegetables no added sugar or fine
grain yes your glycosylated hemo would
would improve your blood sugar would be
down
um you'd be monitoring that so on on
this study LDL cholesterol went up on
keto and down in Mediterranean
triglycerides actually got better on
keto they got better on Mediterranean
but keto was even more better
why would you get rid of beans and
Grains and fruits if if you could
include them and that's that's what I
was having like that's that's too
restrictive why would you need to go to
that level if you took care of 90 of the
problem first you could still enjoy
those interesting I think on a
psychological level for some people
it's if you if regardless of the how
restrictive the protocol is there's
something
easy or comforting about the fact that
you can just say these are off the table
and you can eat these things and so it
makes that decision tree a little bit
simpler and even if it's challenging
from a sustainability point of view
there's something about the Simplicity
of it that makes adherence perhaps
easier or a little bit better have you
found that yeah and again that's as you
started out our conversation yeah this
adherence to whatever the guideline is
for a study
is a huge component of this I don't
really want to go into into intermittent
fasting but I will bring it up just for
the moment because I don't like
intermittent fasting there's no
attention to the quality of the diet
it's just a time thing but I understand
why Americans like it let's see should I
eat now let me look at my watch no
should I eat now let me look at my watch
yes ah thank God that is so clear yeah
it's it's really I agree that it's clear
but I know some people who eat a pretty
crappy diet intermittently fasting in
that long term
that isn't going to do it eat crappy
food in a narrow window you're still
going to have to eat good food it's not
enough
so as somebody who's incredibly steeped
in nutrition science who intimately
knows the details the benefits the pros
the cons of every single you know kind
of protocol out there popular protocol
keto low carb low fat
vegan you know Etc you have been
personally like eating a plant-based
diet for a very long time since 83. so
knowing what you know and seeing that
people can do well on a Mediterranean
diet Etc like why have you decided to
eat this way like there is an argument
to be said for like this is the guy who
spends who's devoted his entire life to
looking at all this stuff here's what
he's learned but like let's just eat
what he like why don't we just let's
just do what he does yeah so walk me
through why you're plant-based or you
know how that fits into you
as a human but also as a scientist yeah
it really all started out with a girl I
got dumped by
1983. from Marina Del Rey in your
neighborhood here okay yeah are you
having a moment being back here yeah I
drove past the area where I was on the
beach where I got dumped it's on the way
40 years ago yeah so that was kind of
funny so I I Did It for the Girl and
then I was like ah wow this is
personally aligned with my values more
actually had never been hunting I
actually hated fishing I thought that's
pretty funny that I could be eating all
this food and have it be inconsistent
with my personal values I'm liking this
oh I'm liking the people that I'm eating
this is fun I'm a pretty active person I
play multiple Sports and I would never
want my sports performance to be
impaired by this or my physical activity
level I I've never really been
overweight I certainly want to maintain
a healthy weight be active be sharp yeah
it's supported that over the years so 83
on I went vegetarian and then
I teach a class at Stanford called food
and society and I've now been teaching
it for 15 years and this is a
pediatrician named Tom Robinson and I
who got into this years ago and there's
a background story that I'll spare you
it's actually all done to collect data
from Stanford students it was going to
be a one-year thing and we decided for
fun
it would be a food related course but we
would never talk about health we had a
handshake and said okay in this class
we're it's going to be called food and
Society
and we're going to deal with animal
rights and Welfare environment and
climate change human labor abuses and
slaughterhouses and fast food
restaurants
but let's not talk any metabolism or any
health and it was career changing for me
to hear the students be very engaged in
social justice issues and they most of
them reported changing their diet in
class and we actually published a paper
on this but let's let's put the paper
aside
one of the books we read was Jonathan
saffron force uh eating animals animals
yeah I went vegan it's like oh yeah I've
been having Dairy all this time
oh yeah all the the male cows go to Veal
Slaughter and all the cows making milk
go in this Factory process and it sounds
pretty horrible why am I supporting that
since I'm not supporting other things so
I can't remember exactly what I don't
know it's 10 or 15 years ago but when
vegan
and I would say my personal philosophy
is you don't need to be vegan I actually
would I prefer the term Whole Food
plant-based
but part of the reason I keep doing it
is I kind of feel a personal
responsibility like hey I'm 64 and I'm
I'm pretty active
shouldn't I stay this way just so I can
hopefully I'll be 75 and then 85 and 95
and say you could do this kind of like
the game changers documentary
I don't think that documentary was
saying you have to do this to be a good
athlete I hope to take your message was
you could you could do this in your
athletic performance would not suffer so
I've done it
uh and this is actually what my book is
getting at so this book that's coming
out that won't be called it depends
each chapter in the book says here's the
metabolism that's going on and here's
the reasons it might be good or bad for
you if you want to ask an answerable
question about whether to avoid it or
eat it but I know for a lot of people
part of that answer to choose it or
avoid it is ethical or is environmental
or is human labor Associated so what if
what if you actually don't believe in
the metabolism or think the metabolism
is important for you but
the ethics are or the environment is or
the human labor is and if if you put all
those together they are all well aligned
with a plant-based diet if you add those
three other factors and I
not only is it well aligned but I think
for a lot of people aligning with your
personal values is more of a motivator
to be able to sustain it
then knowing the metabolism and the
enzyme and the organ that it goes to and
you know it's the kind of thing where
you see this food in front of you and
you just say okay if it's a metabolic
thing I know I'm going to die someday I
know I shouldn't have that but today I
will and tomorrow I won't but if you
look at it and you say oh it's not just
me
I that choice is having a bigger impact
okay I guess I'm not going to eat it I'm
gonna go with a whole food plant-based
diet and in that regard for the people
who are
headed toward vegan but stop short and
they have eggs once in a while and they
have some fish once in a while and I
can't point to a health benefit
that is for 100 vegan versus 95. I don't
think anybody's ever done that study
yeah but in other words what you're
saying is not only is it doable and
healthy to eat this way it's sustained
you for a very long time you're thriving
and vital you know at your age and have
every expectation of being able to
continue to do the active things that
you love doing you're not sacrificing
anything by living this way and you're
able to sustain maintain
um this way of life because it's tied to
a bigger why yeah not just about like
what I want and my blood markers or
whatever my doctor told me but you know
there's a there's an ethical you know
responsibility or or or not obligation
but you know just that that that deeper
sense of like
can I be a little bit of a better person
or is there a better choice that I could
make right here that has a consequence
that's beyond my selfish you know uh uh
taste buds in this moment yeah and that
Jonathan saffron Boar's book was so uh
inspirational for me there is one lying
almost exactly what you said and I won't
be able to quote it but two friends go
to a store and they both want to order a
hamburger and one has it because they
want to have the taste the other one
says that I really would like the taste
but it doesn't seem worth my preference
for taste for all the consequences this
this is going to happen
and are used like uh
self-experimenter where you're always
testing your own blood and your markers
and all that kind of stuff yeah because
I get to just do that to other people
yeah okay no yeah I get to look at my
tmao and my LDL and my small dense ldls
and my yeah all the other things it's
all good I presume yeah I'm pretty good
and I have a massive amount of heart
disease in my family my dad died after
10 cardiovascular procedures wow my
uncle died at 40 of a heart attack and
so yeah I'm at risk of tons of things
and I haven't had any cardiovascular
procedures the 64 and I'm pretty active
and so I I can't prove
that it's my diet but I'd certainly
rather take that chance and to your
point earlier I'm not sacrificing
anything I really enjoy the food that I
eat if you look at Middle Eastern food
Latin American African food I mean
there's so many cultures Asian food so
many cultures around the world that make
fabulous
tasting food my new friends are chefs
I've sort of switched to hanging out
trying to do studies with chefs because
they make unapologetically delicious
food and a lot of it is plant-based yeah
I want to get to that but let me let's
let's push that aside for a moment there
is we were speaking a moment ago about
revising dietary guidelines and how to
think about
um you know what's traditionally known
as the food pyramid or the plate or what
have you and I remember it wasn't that
long ago there was there were some
ripples around
those guidelines being impacted by the
environmental considerations of the food
that we're eating and that caused quite
a kerfuffle publicly people didn't like
that yeah but you know to your point
that you just made it seems like that
should be a consideration like we all
have a greater obligation to the whole
yes Beyond ourselves and these decisions
that we're making every single day do
have a real world impact as much as we
want to avoid really connecting with
that
um
and I think that's something that you've
clearly spent a lot of time thinking
about I would suspect that you would be
a in favor of those considerations being
built into the recommendation structure
I mean how do you feel about that I feel
very strongly and I had the opportunity
to pursue this and write a paper on it
called sort of maximizing the optimal
amount of protein that would be good for
human health and the planet right yep
and I got an environmental scientist to
work with me and a food industry person
to work with me so sort of a
multi-disciplinary group looking at this
and
at the end of the day the conclusion was
if you really understand the protein
guidelines that are out there people
need less than they think they're a
little confused about how much they need
and they think they need a lot and they
need less
I also underestimate how much they get
because they get a lot more protein than
I think
they undervalue plant protein they think
it's missing amino acids and it isn't
they're all there there's a subtle issue
about limiting amino acids but let's not
go there for now it's not a big deal and
it would be we modeled this how easy it
would be to cut back 25 protein and
still meet and exceed requirements
what if you took 25 percent from animal
and shifted it to plant
you would be fine and here would be the
impact on greenhouse gases and water and
land use and other things like that you
would make a huge difference with that
25 25 shift and that was just modeling
it so you could go lower in protein and
you could shift it all to plants and
you'd have a bigger
impact but yeah so I've been having fun
writing that and it actually had to do
with working with these chefs
because they were thinking about this
idea of a protein flip
if you wanted me to go into that because
it's a dietarily it's a pretty fun idea
so a group called the menus of change
that got started by Harvard and The
Culinary Institute of America and the
background story for this is pretty fun
chefs were getting trained at The
Culinary Institute of America going out
and being in restaurants and the public
just kept changing their mind
gluten-free vegan paleo whatever the
popular diet of the month was
and the educational institution was
feeling a little bad for the students
they were promoting into the real world
saying sorry but you're going to have to
be reactive to however the public
changes and said maybe not maybe
we could get in front of this what if
chefs we start defining what the right
things to do are and we could serve our
own menus and be more proactive than
reactive
let's let's get a scientific Advisory
Board a business board and a chef board
and let's put these concentric circles
together and let's see some nutritional
truths that will never change
that make business sense that are
culinarily delicious
and so let's find this intersection of
unapologetically delicious food that's
good for humans and good for the planet
and you can make money making it and
selling it and so they came up with a 24
principles of the menus of change
it's pretty easy fine and the CIA is
awesome at making Graphics they have
fabulous infographics
so look for this iconic thing or there's
Publications on their 24 principles of
the menus of change but one of the
interesting things after establishing
this was
you know what practical food choices
could we suggest that hit multiple
principles at once like what would be
the biggest bang for our buck 24 sounds
like a lot of principles do I do them
one at a time
So at their second annual meeting I
remember them saying ah we have this
idea called the protein flip it actually
came from a previous request we had
about the dessert flip and some folks
had hired them and said we're getting a
lot of flack for how many calories our
desserts have in this age of obesity can
you help us and they said yeah the
dessert flip instead of cheesecake with
a raspberry on top have a bowl of
raspberries and a dollop of Cheesecake
on top it'll be a flip reverse it I
didn't take away your cheesecake I also
have a smaller portion of it and most of
it is fruit and I said
kind of thinking a protein flip idea
could work here so what if instead of
meat being the center of the plate
plants were the center of the plate but
you didn't get rid of the meat it could
be a side dish or a condiment or could
be two ounces of fish or chicken on top
but not 6 or 12 ounces in the middle and
then they freaked out a little and they
said oh but wait that protein thing
oh my God the American public's gonna
freak out they're gonna say where are
they going to get their protein
Christopher will you do uh at our
meeting our second annual meeting can
you do protein 101 I said yes I've been
teaching this at Stanford for years I
have like four hours of lecture
materials how much time can I have I
said eight minutes
hahaha eight oh my God okay okay eight
so I boiled it down to what I could and
I finished and their mouths were wide
open they said no
I said no
this is the real thing plants have
protein they have enough they have all
the amino acids they said next year you
can have 20 minutes the year after that
they gave me an hour the year after that
a sports convention invited me to give a
two-hour talk and so that paper that I
was just describing about maximizing
human health and planetary health
grab probably 50 talks I've now given on
protein I actually never did a
controlled randomized trial on it
I was actually just looking at
metabolism and food and amino acids and
starting to hang out with chefs and
environmental scientists
I'm sort of putting this all together
much like the Lancet report did the eat
Lancer report in 2019
and it it's all there it totally
justifies this protein flip idea which
can be unapologetically delicious but
plant-based you could leave the meat off
if you want to be all Whole Food
plant-based or you could leave it on if
that's an easier way for you to make
this transition and it would make a huge
impact for human health and the health
of the planet yeah that's really
beautifully articulated and and such a a
worthy Mission you know but I think in
thinking about protein as much as the
tribalism lives and breathes around low
carb low-fat keto Etc
um there is a a really kind of emotional
resonance or or persistence around this
idea that somehow we're protein lacking
and we should be eating more protein not
less yeah plant protein is inferior uh
yes plants have all the amino acids but
something about bioavailable
bioavailability blah blah blah it's just
not quite as good and if you want to
maintain your muscle mass particularly
as we age and I'm getting up there as
well uh you need to be increasing your
protein intake so like walk me through I
mean I don't have four hours but I have
more than eight minutes to devote to
getting some clarity on on this from
your perspective yeah and actually
there's a meta-analysis by uh Stu
Phillips's group I'm blanking on the
first author and they recently updated
it and I and I don't have the updated
paper
sort of the conclusion of this
meta-analysis looking at multiple
studies about resistance training and
either muscle mass or muscle strength
was trying to show the optimal amount of
protein that you need in it it was sort
of getting at supplementation like when
do you need to supplement and if you
look at the conclusion of the paper
it says you know once you get to 1.6
grams of protein per kilogram body
weight
after that
it you don't really need supplementation
it doesn't really matter and so there's
an important Point here
is that the recommended daily allowance
of protein is 0.8 grams per kilogram
body weight so this 1.6
would be double the RDA
but I want to walk it back a little
before that even so when the nutrition
Community came up with this
the recommended daily allowance is a
principle that holds for lots of
different nutrients and what you do is
you find sort of the normal distribution
of nutrient need
and everybody needs slightly different
number just depending on how big or
active they are whatever and in the
protein in particular the average is
called the estimated average requirement
of protein
and it's 0.66 grams per kilogram body
weight lower a protein why then is the
RDA 0.8 and the whole idea here is if
the average requirement is 0.66 and
everyone got average
but upper half would be screwed they
wouldn't be getting enough so in the
field of nutrition
for vitamins and minerals and protein
the RDA is two standard deviations
higher
than the average requirement this is
just a simple principle so think of this
answer this question if everybody got
exactly the RDA how many people would
exceed their requirement and by
definition in math that's 97.5 would
exceed
their requirement okay so 0.8 grams per
kilogram per day
is intended to exceed the requirement of
the American population eating their
diet if you look at n Haynes data that's
the national health and nutrition
examination survey
it states that Americans 1.2 to 1.5
grams protein per kilogram body weight
so if these muscle Builders are trying
to gain weight and they need 1.6 grams
per kilogram body weight that's kind of
what the American public eats anyway
already yeah but my point here is so let
me add a Twist to this if you're trying
to gain muscle
if you're working out hard enough to
gain muscle don't you have to eat more
calories than the American public and as
soon as you eat more calories
you you surpassed yeah you're you're
automatically no matter what increasing
your protein over that and so the idea
and Stu Phillips you know we had a
conversation actually on Simon's uh
podcast it was billed as a debate that
it was going to be the gardener Phillips
debate and they were going to go at it
and he really doesn't like that 0.8
grams per kilogram by the way he thinks
that's wrong and I if you wanted to get
into that I could say I agree with some
of his points of why it's wrong but I
think it's kind of moot
because when people eat protein they eat
20 of their calories from protein they
eat 2 400 calories a day and they get
1.6 grams per kilogram anyway and one of
his the point eight isn't even isn't
even anything to discuss yes no one's
eating that that little if you got that
low that would be an issue but I
actually have a textbook that I use uh
one of the quotes from the textbook is
uh assuming you're eating a reasonable
variety of food in the diet if you had
no beef no chicken no fish no egg no
cheese
it would be almost impossible not to get
0.8 grams per kilogram per day just if
you were getting enough food so Stu
Phillips conclusion is
ninety percent of your your muscle
strength building maintenance is the
workout less than 10 percent
is diet and so you don't need protein
supplementation you don't even need that
extra chicken breast
if if you're eating enough food to
support your workout you'll most likely
get it I know this to be true for myself
just based on personal experience when I
was training my very hardest in my early
and mid mid 40s putting in just you know
I don't know 20 hours a week 25 hours a
week at the peak
and at that time
seeing pretty rapid gains in in my
fitness and my endurance and having no
issues whatsoever building lean muscle
mass
and my protein intake which I was pretty
closely monitoring just was not
excessive at all
yeah and it made me realize like there's
so much misplaced emphasis or concern on
this particular macronutrient and if
you're just randomly grazing
even predominantly on plant-based Foods
Nature has it rigged that you're going
to be taken care of had nature not had
it rigged maybe we wouldn't have made it
yeah like it's it's built in yes it's a
it's a Fail-Safe sort of you know eat it
and forget it sort of thing and yet this
idea continues to really you know become
an obsession for a lot of people and and
there is a lot of discussion right now
around what to do when we're aging so
does that change as you get into your
mid 60s like in you really have to worry
about maintaining your muscle mass
because that's such a primary factor in
terms of longevity yeah and so that's
not not an area of specialization for me
and so I haven't done any studies in
that area but you know when I talk to
people about sarcopenia
muscle loss issues like that yes protein
in the diet is an issue but a bigger
issue for sarcopenia is dentition
loneliness depression being in a
facility you know a retirement facility
where the food doesn't taste it's just
not eating enough food
and so if you weren't eating enough food
yes you should get a higher
concentration of protein in the small
amount of food
that you're eating
but if you were physically and mentally
active and out there and working out
you probably wouldn't need that much
more protein it would it's some of these
other related issues to muscle loss as
you age having a more sedentary
lifestyle
it's much more complex than not getting
enough protein I would be all in favor
of saying yes and this isn't true so the
US has not upgraded the RDA for older
adults it's still 0.8 grams per kilogram
people have said make it 1.0 grams per
kilogram body weight I would be fine
with that if if you did have access to a
reasonable amount of variety in your
diet you'd easily surpass that right
interesting if you're not then you might
not have access to that food there might
be what if there's food insecurity
nutrition and security issues going on
what if you are lonely or depressed what
if you don't like the food that they're
serving in the retirement community what
if you really are sedentary there are a
lot of issues to address there
interesting yeah I uh
that makes a lot of sense
um
it's hard to talk about
longevity
in terms of specific variables like that
because there are so many things that
come into play and I think the community
piece the connection piece the sense of
purpose the ikigai and all of that
probably is the most predominant like as
you age losing that sense of connection
and purpose in your life yeah leads to
Rapid decline
probably more so than your protein yeah
yeah it's it's one of those things with
people yeah I think the protein issue
could be relevant at the margin there
are a lot of other issues to address
continuing this exploration of protein
uh another thing that there's a lot of
energy around right now is is
um the health implications of of
plant-based meat uh these these Burger
analogs Etc
um these processed versions of meat
products that have found their way into
mainstream culture all the way to the
Fast Food Outlet such that now we are
blessed with choice we don't have to get
a cheeseburger we can get a beyond meat
Burger we can get an impossible Burger
but I think a lot of people are are
wondering well okay it's not meat but
it's processed there seems to be you
know a fair amount of chemicals in these
things or saturated fat like is this
really better for me than the the
regular burger is it worse are they the
same this question occurred to you yes
you said well let's look into this and
figure it out so walk me through this
swap meet trial that you did okay and
first I hope everybody will appreciate
the acronym swap meet means sub uh study
with appetizing plant food a meat eating
alternative trial oh I didn't even know
that I just thought swap meet of course
that's what you know it makes sense on
its face we're pretty happy with our
acronym so I hope you like that yeah
that's very cheeky and uh what came to
me was three full-page ads in the New
York Times from uh meet supporting group
saying oh my God don't eat these
plant-based alternative Meats they're
practically dog food they're all Ultra
processed yes maybe they're better for
the environment for these things that
they're saving but they're going to be
bad for your health because they have
saturated fat from the coconut oil they
have high sodium and they're also
processed and Kevin Hall did a beautiful
study on gaining weight with ultra
processed food so you don't don't want
to gain weight have high blood pressure
have high LDL cholesterol
don't eat them and I thought oh my god
this is my superpower I know how to
design studies looking at exactly those
things me me call on me okay so
um full acknowledgment here Beyond me
paid for this study I am an industry
shill for having taken the money well
let's just let's would the NIH have
given me money yeah I don't think so and
it was a relevant question and so I I
applied the most rigor I could but I
just want to acknowledge that up front
and let's ruminate in that subject just
for a moment though because I think it's
important
um obviously when you see a study uh
that was paid for by a lobbying group uh
and the results of that study favor the
lobbying group's political perspective
you're going to question it right when
the dairy when you see this study that
says chocolate milk is the world's best
you know recovery drink and you see that
it was paid for by the dairy Lobby well
I'm like all right well really is that
what's going on here
um likewise it's low hanging fruit
criticism for you to say well beyond
meat paid for this yeah we'll get into
the results but the results were not
unfavorable the beyond meat in this
regard so uh you know uh duh right so
the truth being that it is more
complicated than that in terms of how
these studies are structured and where
the firewalls are placed and that
applies to whether the dairy Lobby paid
for our study or beyond meat paid for a
study yeah so you should be skeptical
but you shouldn't dismiss it so a lot of
studies wouldn't get done if they didn't
get paid for by the food industry so you
should take the time to look at it and
if you don't understand it ask somebody
to explain the pros and cons of the
study design and quite often the bias is
blatant
and in our study we took every
opportunity possible to make this
objective science and I stand by it to
this day so put it aside for now and
talk about the study yeah except to say
also on top of that because I want to be
I don't want to come off biased either
like you know
um
I'm sure you would have preferred
private funding or the NIH to have
funded this yes and so that's a broader
conversation around how the whole
ecosystem of securing funding for these
studies operates right like it's a it's
hard to get money to do these things and
they are expensive and on one level you
got to take the money wherever you can
get it try to protect the protocols as
best as you can
um
but there's also I'm sure compromises
that you had to make or have seen your
colleagues make because is doing the
study better uh than not doing it right
because of yeah Source Etc like again
you know it depends right like it
depends applies to this it does well
yeah I part of my I actually had a big
tutorial before I released the study
showing here's the things I did to
protect the objectivity of the science
so if you ever want to look for my
tutorial on that which was part of it I
will just say was Six industry-funded
studies that I did that all failed they
were all null findings I published all
of them so that's just part of my
defense I I did the science they didn't
work I published the null findings did
they did not want you to publish or just
sometimes they say if it's negative you
can't publish is that part of the no so
Stanford won't let me take the money
unless I get to publish whatever I find
so some very strict guidelines that
Stanford doesn't want their name brand
sacrificed for this yeah no I have to
get to publish and they can't have any
say over it even if it's no right but
all right go forward going forward so
real fun in designing this study was
what do we control for what do we let
run wild
um what do we provide what do we not
provide what's the comparison group one
of the first questions is what's the
dose so if we want to do this
what's the dose should we say uh Beyond
Burger once a week that's not enough
Beyond Burger every day
uh I'm not even sure if that's enough
all you get is beyond burger or red meat
okay that nobody's gonna do that so this
is supposed to be for eight weeks each
so we can see cardio metabolic risk
factors to change so here's one of these
questions that you started in your
original conversation we decided two
servings a day
of red meat or beyond me
could some somebody could say what about
three what about one and a half yes we
only did it with two so I can only
answer this with two What proportion of
your calories was that it was a quarter
of their calories so three quarters of
their calories they were getting
themselves on their own and they were
responsible for it and in the Run
whatever they wanted
whatever they wanted with the acceptance
you said as part of this study we're not
going to provide the rest of the food we
will deliver the beyond meat or the red
meat but the rest like if let's just
take a burger for a simple example if
you're we really want you to have the
whole grain bun and the arugula lettuce
and the farmer's market tomato on there
with Organic ketchup if you do that for
one phase it's a crossover everybody was
doing both
you have to do it for the other phase
two
if and we don't want this if you have a
white bun and iceberg lettuce and high
sugar ketchup or something on one phase
you have to have it on the other face so
that the other 75 percent
is as close as possible between the two
phases and the only thing different is
this 25 of calories
from two servings a day of beyond meat
and it wasn't just Burgers so beyond
meat makes crumbles and they had a
chicken at that point and they had
sausages
and they had patties
so we did that
and think of this so who could we choose
for the red meat should we get crappy
red meat so that they have a better
chance of winning no we went to a San
Francisco company
that sourced totally from organic
regenerative farming all the right words
so that it was high quality and very
expensive red meat that we were
delivering and in parallel we would
deliver the same proportion of burgers
versus ground beef versus chicken versus
sausage
that they want there's a little a little
personalization there you got to choose
whatever you wanted in the first phase
and had to match that
in the second phase and then we looked
at all the nutrients so what do you get
nutrient wise when you do this and it
turned out yes beyond meat the coconut
oil has saturated fat but it was less
than the saturated fat in the red meat
um
yes the beyond meat has uh sodium added
to it and ground beef has no sodium but
you know what the participants salted
their unsodium containing ground beef
and the sodium levels were identical on
the two phases interesting uh
calorie wise they were totally matched
on calories so very similar between the
two
fiber beyond meat was more fiber
uh it was more of certain antioxidants
and so we sort of have a whole higher in
carb uh protein was the same actually
protein was virtually identical because
of the way they make their products
so we we put these head-to-head in a in
a nutrient context to show the relevant
nutrients for LDL cholesterol and blood
pressure and tmao trimethylamine oxide
this thing that gets generated when you
have red meat this emerging new risk
factor
Etc and at the end of the day and we can
go back if you need
uh
in this crossover study with everybody
doing both phases on the beyond meat
there LDL went down their weight went
down their tmao went down and their
blood pressure stayed the same
on both phases so if you go back to that
New York Times front page article that
said oh my God this is going to kill you
because the LDL cholesterol goes up no
it went down
uh your weight is going to go up because
of the Kevin Hall study nope actually
went down a little not up your blood
pressure is going to Skyrocket nope
stayed the same it was the same amount
of sodium and tmao is sort of emerging
new thing it's not a typical clinical
thing
that went down to so nothing got better
on red meat then beyond meat and beyond
meat had three things that got better
than red meat and as soon as I finished
people said so this is what you want
people to eat not lentils I said
no that's not the question
the question was instead of
red meat
I didn't say instead of lentils I've
been trying to get people to eat lentils
and chickpeas forever and a lot of
people won't do it they're still eating
their red meat but they might
have Beyond or impossible rather than
red meat what would happen that's the
question right it was very limited to
that one comparison yeah um a couple
interesting thoughts on that
um so just so we're clear
each population did eight weeks of each
right yeah so not each population the
the adult population so 36 individuals
right eight weeks of
beyond meat and then organic beef and
then another in the opposite orders okay
okay so so but all of them did it meet
first and then beyond meat or some of
them did the other way around randomly
assigned to order okay so half and half
yeah and one interesting Insight was
that
people who did the pl correct me if I'm
wrong people who did the plant-based uh
eight weeks first
um
had uh didn't bump their tmao when they
went to the meat as much yeah and this
is this is kind of inside baseball but
it's pretty fun for me so I'm happy to
talk about it it's pretty fun
okay quick one step back before I say
that so you can do two kinds of studies
in an intervention you can do parallel
where everybody only does a or only does
B
or you can do crossover where everybody
does both and people like the crossover
because they want to compare for
themselves how they did in both phases
a problem comes up if whatever you did
on the first phase influences the second
phase hence washouts statistical prop
but even with a washout so washouts are
quite problematic because it's hard to
decide should it be a day or a week or a
month explain what that is for people
that don't know what to wash out so the
washout would be you finish part a
and let's say there were changes it
would be best if the changes went back
to how they were in the beginning when
they were randomized so you have to know
how much time it would take
for everybody to get back and you have
them go back to their usual diet
for as I said a day or a week or four
weeks and our primary outcome in this
study according to clinicaltrials.gov
was this tmao trimethylamine oxide there
aren't really any data on how long it
would take to go if it changes how long
it would take to go back and we chose
not to do a washout my feeling is the
phases were eight weeks long the main
comparison is week eight versus week
eight whatever kind of thing was going
on would be washed out anyway
by eight weeks and so I'm only going to
compare the end
we can go back to that if you want but
this study had no washout you did one
for eight weeks
and you search the other one you've got
an unexpected result which may have been
due to the lack of washout which for me
was pretty fun
so let's start with the group that got
animal first so when they got meat first
their tmao went up
now interestingly you couldn't be
vegetarian to be in the study because we
didn't think vegetarians be willing to
eat red meat you had to be a meat eater
if you were already a meat eater why did
their tmao go up well looking back they
were really eating one serving a day of
red meat so when we moved them to two
servings a day of red meat that was
higher right tmao went up on average it
didn't actually go up in everybody but
it went up enough to be statistically
significant
and that when they switched to the
plant-based meat within two weeks it
dropped and it stayed down for the next
six in that group so I have a beautiful
graphic of showing that and it's very
clean
and then switch to the group that got
plant meat first so these were meat
eaters their tmao level wasn't very high
to begin with it went down a bit
certainly didn't go up
and after eight weeks they switched to
meat
and we expected the tmao to shoot up and
it didn't it didn't really go up at all
so partly this is not what we expected
and super fun to think about
geekily from science it's like crap
there was a carryover effect something
that happened in phase one for plant
first didn't jive with what happened and
the ones who got animal first
oh my God now there's sort of a problem
for me collapsing the two orders and
treating them like they are identical
it was actually still statistically
significant even when you match them and
it didn't happen in one order the
overall was still statistically
significant but what I thought was
really fun
was going to the literature saying oh my
God how did this happen and what looks
like it was the explanation we actually
have some stool samples being analyzed
right now to see if this is it
is on the plant-based diet they changed
their microbiome and generating tmao
relies on a conversion of these two
molecules and meet carnitine and choline
in the gut from the microbiome
and so if eight weeks of being vegan
modified their internal milia their
microbiome so they no longer were
supporting the microbes that converted
to tml meant they were kind of protected
in the second phase so as much as it was
annoying for me to explain in the study
what went on
it was also kind of this personalized
nutrition cool thing like oh my God they
did this thing first and they didn't
have the same response as the other
folks this is another hint that the
microbiome is important right first this
this uh very interesting Alliance that
you now have with the sonnenbergs yes
we I used to call myself a feeder and a
bleeder because of all my studies with
cholesterol and tmao and Insulin glucose
and now I'm a feeder and bleeder and
pooper yeah it's all it's all about the
poop now right I get poop from everyone
which I initially assumed okay this is
so icky no one will do this
everyone is willing to give their Putin
like I never get through discussing the
whole study
and then mention the poop and they say
oh you had me until now but if you want
poop I'm out it doesn't happen people
are fascinated to learn
about their microbiome and they're
willing to do it and I have all the
in the freezer to prove it it is
it is amazing how much poop we have in
the freezer people want to know it's a
really fun topic and it's so emergent
you know it's exciting because it's new
and technology has you know sort of
progressed to the point where you're
able to extract information that
wouldn't have been possible not that
long ago which makes it like this new
frontier and Stanford's working on the
smart toilet so it'll collect it oh wow
um you know indirectly after you use the
toilet there's like a butt imprint so it
knows who sat on the toilet or there's a
finger imprint on the thing with the
Privacy landscape of like now even my
toilet has to know what's happening all
the time yeah it's I'm imagining uh the
powers that be over at Zoe thinking we
could we could we could come up with
some use cases for the personalized
toilet yeah capturing these samples and
doing what we do with them it is a
really fun New Field wow
um
just to kind of put a put a button on
the whole um swap meet thing I'm
interested in the follow-up study that
you did where you basically took this
and applied it to athletes with a with a
tweak
um not Stanford versus the athletes but
like really active athletic students at
Stanford sort of in maybe in some part
in response to game changers like how
does this swap meet thing work for
people who are concerned about you know
how fast they can run or how much they
can lift right Jim I mean again given
this is a protein issue and so many
athletes are obsessed with how much
protein they get
I most of my Studies have been in older
adults with cardio metabolic risk
factors and they involve blood and poop
but a pretty simple thing is strength
and performance
so I had a master's student who really
liked this first idea and she was a
runner and she said you know what ideas
can you come up with for an honors
thesis for me I said God I've been
really wanting to work with athletes
especially now that I've got into
protein and all this bias that you need
protein what if we replicated swap meet
among athletes
and added that arm that people
complained to me about added the vegan
arm and so now we'll have omnivore
versus vegan and vegan plus two servings
of plant meat a day and you got you
nailed this right so actually this is
during the pandemic it had been designed
to be done in dining halls with
undergrads but they were all gone and
the dining Halls were closed she still
needed a an honors thesis and so we
advertised among grad students who
interestingly stayed on campus to do
their research they didn't have to go to
so many classes so they were allowed to
stay
and we advertise for only recreational
lifters and Runners because so we didn't
want a training effect we didn't want
while you're on this diet we have to
figure out what the training effect is
being on we want you to be running at
your best right now lifting at your best
right now and if you switched your diet
would that improve your import
performance or impair your performance
or or nothing and our hypothesis was
nothing it wouldn't change it why not I
know the answer to this but why not just
go to The Varsity athletes go to the
pool go to the track go to the
basketball the coaches won't let me
touch their teams uh and interestingly
I've been approached once in a while by
a coach says oh here we have a nutrition
Professor on campus so what do you think
about this I said well the literature's
limited but this uh but if on off season
I could mess with your players nope
thank you anyway goodbye like and I kind
of get it they paid all this I know they
put a lot of effort into their varsity
teams
yeah
but in their off season okay never mind
that that has never gone very far but
you know having having closed that door
I actually think that in terms of
generalizability I like this
recreational athlete thing how many
folks are out there that they care about
their performance because they've been
running for or Lifting for their
personal health for years and they
intend to keep doing it
for years and they might have considered
changing their diet but thinking well I
don't want performance to suffer I'm not
competing I'm not going in some event
but I I still like how fast I run and
how much I lift yeah it's much more
relatable and applicable yeah I mean we
can look at the Olympic Athlete but the
reality is most people like to your
point is this going to make me weaker am
I going to be slower and more sluggish
if I eat this way am I somehow impairing
my physical capabilities by not eating
this and eating this instead yeah
and so there are some limitations of the
study because it was only 22 people it
was only four weeks it was a crossover
again so everybody did all three phases
which really makes recruitment easier
because they were curious that you could
tell the people who signed up were like
I've thought about this before but I I
never was really a reason and a
structure yeah if there's a study and
I'm not only going to learn what happens
to me but happens to others like me who
are trying this I would be interested in
this and and the bottom line is the
running and the strength training did
not change among the three four week
arms over time and it was really
irrespective of group these three groups
basically result on parity and very
importantly vegans got less protein
plant protein was in the Beyond Burger
or the plant-based Meats were in the
middle and omnivores had the highest
protein the envoirs had the lowest carb
and the lowest fiber the plant-based
meat in the middle and the vegans had
the highest fiber and the highest carbs
and you can see similar things for
saturated fat and cholesterol I mean if
if this wasn't a match like I'm not
matching protein and cholesterol
unsaturated fat if I'm just having the
meat plant-based versus omnivore
and plus plant-based meat Alternatives
everything went in the direction that
you would think many of the nutrients
were different and what the I think the
Aubry Roberts did very nicely in this
was look at some of the sports
guidelines out there showing that even
with fewer carbs the weight weight
lifters were getting enough carbs and
even with less protein the vegans were
getting enough protein
and this idea that you have to maximize
these things is is a little unnecessary
if you're eating a healthy mixed diet
you're getting enough carbs and enough
protein interesting and we should point
out that that study was not funded by
beyond meat yeah actually that was
almost a nothing so we just Aubry did
all the work on this and because
um the outcomes were a composite score
of a lap pull down a bench press and a
leg press that doesn't cost anything
and the perform the runner's performance
was a 12 minute timed run
that doesn't cost anything so Aubry did
all the work uh and I'm happy to say
that we had 24 grad students sign up and
22 did everything which is pretty good
from a dropout rate yeah it's a Stanford
student they're good students they know
how to like follow directions yeah they
were really fun to work with and they
were really interesting to talk with
about these results and yeah it was a
blast working with them
the study that I think a lot of people
would like to see performed is the
plant-based versus carnivore
so walk me through where your head is at
with this and why or why not that would
be a good idea and how it could even
conceivably be structured yeah so uh on
paper that sounds fascinated there's
actually quite a few fascinating things
in nutrition it could be done
and you can start you could start
looking at mechanisms you could start
looking at observational epidemiology
who is a vegan who is a carnivore
at the end of the day we've had a bunch
of examples in nutrition beta carotene
being one vitamin E being another one
outside of nutrition hormone replacement
therapy being another where all the
mechanisms and the observational data
pointed One Direction so clearly
that it seemed almost unethical to do a
randomized control trial but if you
really want to know cause and effect you
have to do that at the end in other
words saying everything that you know
about nutrition over the many decades
that you've been looking at this you
can't in good conscience
uh Corral a population of people and
compel them to eat only meat for however
long yeah yeah if you took all the
existing data you couldn't definitively
say this is this you'd want the
randomized control trial but uh what
most if I want your listeners to feel my
pain so for whatever question you ask I
have to recruit them I have to say I
have funding I'm going to run a study
you have to do this or that and my
students will often say yeah I'll sign
up for that I said do you realize what
the comparison Group is because like if
it's a coffee study you have to agree to
drink coffee for the next 10 years or
not you have to be fine with avoiding
all coffee or never giving up coffee if
it's an alcohol study you do have to
agree to drink all the time or never
drink but let's go to omnivore versus
let's go for carnivore versus vegan
who would be willing for some duration
of time longer than a day
longer than a week longer than a month
to be meaningful this would have to be
quite a while
let's say at least six months or a year
sure I'd be happy either way I'd be
happy going vegan or have been going
carnivore
uh you can't you can't possibly talk me
into trying to recruit for that stuff I
is there any any wisdom though in in
doing it for 30 days or 60 days like do
you think you could extrapolate enough
actionable helpful information from a
shorter truncated period of time
you could but then you'd have to say we
need a follow-up to study to see if they
can sustain these and that the thing for
me is having done the A to Z study which
was Atkins versus ornish which are both
quite extreme for 12 months
even at three months which is of all the
time points we had three months was the
peak of enthusiasm for them they weren't
doing Atkins and ornish at three months
at six they were doing it last at 12
many who had gone
astray and so if you're gonna say yeah
I'm going to do a one month study and
I'm gonna see what happens to these
cardio metabolic risk factors or weight
or other things in a short amount of
time
I mean Kevin Hawk could do this did this
he did well not carnivore but he did a
keto versus very low fat vegan and
showed fascinating changes in two weeks
on both groups in terms of energy intake
in terms of body composition
but you you really need more people than
the number he gets to do in his studies
and you need longer amounts of time
you could you could do it you could
report on it and I would be super
skeptical
will that metabolic change continue
and could they continue the diet and if
they can't what
how much help yeah is this study
providing yeah yeah yeah what is your
perspective on that diet and some of the
um
information that's being spread around
the internet regarding LDL regarding
cholesterol regarding the importance or
lack thereof of fiber in the diet like
there's there's a lot of people who are
experimenting with this diet many of
which are are claiming it to be
transformational in terms of how they
feel their weight their energy levels
Etc I'm sure you've you know seen this
and have spent some time thinking about
this
yeah and I think there's there is a
subset of people that have done this
long term
this is also a subset of vegans who have
done this long term I I have a hard time
getting people to stay vegan uh in some
of our in the general population but I
know there's people
who've done it for a long long time for
the carnivores
um yeah it's it's so restrictive I would
want to see it for longer shorter term
as a nutrition scientist you can't get
all the nutrients
how to meet
you can't and fiber
all of us think fiber is is one of the
nutrients of note that people aren't
getting enough of already
and this is clearly far less there's no
fiber in meat I don't know I guess you
could take fiber supplements but that
would be
I'm not ready for fiber supplements yet
there are so many nutrients that you
need to get from a varied diet a varied
diet that we all evolved on forever had
all the food that was available
she actually I remember a nice YouTube
video of there isn't a paleo diet
there's probably eight paleo diets
depending on what part of the world
you evolved in and it was whatever was
fresh and seasonal because there wasn't
a food industry around but to focus on
one food group alone
yeah I just after all my years of
training I there's no way I could
support that it doesn't have all the
nutrients
what do you say to the person who says
all this stuff about elevated LDL is
misunderstood if you're on the carnivore
diet and you're experiencing that you
have nothing to worry about yeah so I
come from the Stanford prevention
Research Center which is a division of
the Department of Medicine and my
division Chief is a cardiologist and he
sees these people in his Cardiology
clinic and it it worries him and he's
concerned
um yeah yes people yes I know my LDL is
Sky High and it's no problem because I
read this here and he says Nope that is
wrong I really need to put you on a
Statin I'd really rather have you change
your diet oh but the small dense LDL
versus the large puffy the whole
particle size I actually my first major
paper was on LDL particle size so I've
actually known about this since 1996.
one of my studies that had to do with a
Stanford group I was working with helped
to establish small dense LDL as an
independent risk factor for
cardiovascular disease and there is
something there but it's one of these at
the margin things
yeah yeah the particle size matters but
a sky-high LDL
it isn't diminished by the fact that
maybe they're larger and fluffier
particles so one of the things that
people in clinical world are moving
towards is an apob
count is the number of particles out
there
and April when April B goes up it's
probably more powerful than LDL
cholesterol the number of particles you
have and on a carnivore diet or a
ketogenic diet it's up with that
saturated fat
it's up and clinically from everything I
know
it's not good for you you can't dismiss
this with particle size
apob being the new kind of more accurate
more definitive way to assess your
cardiovascular disease risk and so it's
because so LDL stands for low density
lipoprotein cholesterol this is a goofy
story if you'll allow me 30 seconds if
you go back 60 years instead of a
centrifuge somebody used an ultra
centrifuge and spun it like 24 000
revolutions per second per minute
for 24 hours in a blood sample and it
would really make particles in the blood
sample separate and that's why it's
called low density lipoprotein high
density life of protein cholesterol
there's a very low density there's an
intermediate density
after this Ultra centrifugation it's
split based on
Dent who cares what the hell the density
is oh it was just a very practical thing
and then what they found was
oh these these are all related to this
family of things called lipoproteins
which carry fat but on their outside
surface there are little balls that go
through your blood that have cholesterol
and protein and phospholipids on the
outside of the particle and some of the
proteins one is called apolipoprotein B
there's actually a b48 and a B100 and
there's an apoe and there's an apoc but
let's not go there the APO B
tends to be a really good reflection of
the actual number of the particles
that are these lipoproteins circulating
in the blood and so rather than worry
about how fluffy or puffy or small or
dense they are
one is just LDL happens to basically
just have this APO B100 so why don't we
just look at the APO right and it's like
a proxy for this is probably better than
LDL cholesterol itself is the number of
and so when people say oh statistically
I have the LDL cholesterol the HDL
cholesterol I have the triglyceride and
I have the apob and the apoc and the
apoe huh APO B looks like a better
mathematical predictor of who gets heart
disease and who doesn't even better than
LDL cholesterol so it's sort of come
down to if if you have that assay and
it's not a standard clinical measure
that might even be better and so on a
carnivore diet the APO B is way up the
LDL is up
clinicians I feel like are only at the
beginning of actually even advising this
test so if people are listening and
they're concerned about their cardiac
health I would suggest that you
specifically ask yeah for that marker
when you do your next blood test and I'd
specifically ask for insulin so here's
another twist along those same lines so
in the community of metabolism
yes we know that blood sugar is a really
important marker but people who are
pre-diabetic tend to be insulin
resistant which could mean that your
glucose levels are actually still being
maintained at a non-diabetic level at
the expense of very high insulin insulin
is not a standard clinical measure
and it's amazing how much we all
understand that an insulin Spike
is really important if you got to blood
pressure or blood glucose or LDL HDL
cholesterol there are National
standardization programs so if you had
your blood measured at any Clinic you'd
be reasonably comfortable knowing that
they're probably very replicable across
Labs not for insulin so we've never had
an insulin standardization program so
it's not a standard clinical measure so
if they're going to ask about their apob
ask about your insulin too because there
actually is some movement afoot
to make insulin a standard clinical
that's interesting yeah I hadn't even
thought about that as somebody who's
played around with cgms and the like
you're thinking about your your blood
glucose level but that's only relevant
in proportion to how much insulin you're
putting out and it's if you are putting
out too much insulin and your curve
looks healthy
you're not really seeing the whole
picture potentially in one of the
studies we did we had 60 people in a
pilot project and they had to be
non-diabetic so their glucose had to be
under control and we did this that oral
glucose tolerance test we get the 75
grams of glucose and you measure blood
at 0 30 minutes 60 and 120 and I plotted
all the insulin curves and for the best
person versus the worst person the worst
person had 40 times the insulin
production of the first one
they were both non-diabetic wow so that
for that person who had 40 times as much
probably got diabetes within the next
year but but that person had even if
that person had a CGM wouldn't know it
would it would look fine maybe not fine
but it wouldn't look like ah I'm not too
much out of range yeah I'm not out of
range for sure I'm okay but it was at
the expense of there pancreas was
cranking out insulin
keep it there and there's some point
when you exhaust the pancreas's ability
right right wow you could know that
ahead of time if insulin was a standard
clinical measure yeah and it's not ask
your doctor that too why is there no
standardization of that don't know you
have to ask the endocrinological society
and I do think there's a movement afoot
to make it a standardized measure it's
easy for me to get as a research method
but here's a fun thing so when I in all
our studies we hand our results back and
insulin is one of the ones we have to
say this is not a standard clinical
measure you can bring this to your
doctor if you want we can't tell you
anything about it because we don't have
a standardized cutoff for a high or low
you were higher or lower than the rest
of the people in the study but this is
for research purposes only in the lab
that does this for us won't give it to
us unless we put that disclaimer
on the report that we are not clinicians
this is not a this is a research value
this is not a clinical value interesting
wow after all these years I'm actually
kind of stunned that that hasn't
happened yet huh
is that like a like a cover your ass
litigation thing
for the yeah for well I don't know about
the left I think yeah because that we
don't have this it's just they've been
doing it for 20 years with me and they'd
keep right but since they've been doing
it for 20 years hasn't somebody stepped
up and said why don't we just we have a
lipid National standardization program
we have a glucose National
standardization but why don't we have
and you know what you have to do for
this is every year your lab gets an
anonymous blood sample or two or ten and
you have to analyze it and report back
and it has to be in the range that got
done in a standardized lab and if it's
outside they have you check your
equipment maybe your reagents are out of
date or something but there's some
monitoring
of how comparable they are to the rest
of the country yeah yeah why don't you
just do that with insulin how hard could
that be it's not an expensive assay it's
a radio immunoassay I mean I feel like
that should get dealt with immediately
given the incredible rise in
pre-diabetes insulin resistance type 2
like this the curve on that is insane
this is something that's impacting so
many people and is going to continue to
only accelerate and this is an important
um thing to have wrapped around you know
your heads and where everybody is with
it and that's easier than a microbiome
standardization or an inflammatory
standardization oh my God if we're not
have insulin how the hell are we going
to get the inflammatory number or the
microbiome number can we at least have
insulin right before I let you go I do
want to spend a few minutes on this idea
of stealth nutrition which is this
really cool thing that you've you've
pioneered that I think is interesting in
the context of what we were speaking
about earlier like what are the most
important things to look at you know we
can have fun on the margin cases over
here but when we look at the big issues
that we can all agree upon in terms of
what we should eat and should should be
avoiding stealth nutrition kind of plays
into that
same philosophy in terms of what are we
really doing here in terms of moving the
Needle And getting people to eat better
and where should we be focusing our time
in our energy yeah and this all came
about because of this class that I was
teaching where we agreed never to talk
about health only to talk about animal
rights and Welfare environmental
concerns and human labor issues and it
was career changing for me to see how
engaged the Stanford students were in
those issues saying hey I they'd come
early to class they'd be talking about
they'd stay after class he'd be saying I
sent this book to my parents I'm trying
to get my brother to change my roommate
doesn't want to talk to me anymore
because every time I come back from this
class I'm talking about this thing and
they're annoyed that I'm so obsessed
with this thing it's like that never
happened when I talked about how cool
cholesterol metabolism is this is really
fascinating and a clarification I want
to point out is stealth nutrition is not
about being deceitful
I think for a lot of people who first
hear this term for me they say oh it's
cauliflower rice it's not real rice and
you fake them out by like sticking block
broccoli into this thing but didn't tell
them no it's not deceit at all the
stealth part is just hey I'd like to
talk about metabolism and health oh
you're not interested okay animal rights
and Welfare oh don't you pet your dog
and don't you love cows and pigs and
yeah I'm still not getting a reaction
the environment how about land use water
use Greenhouse oh I'm seeing you perk up
okay so I had this other tool in my tool
test so you're interested in the
environment can I tell you from a
protein perspective the impact of animal
Foods versus plant foods and now I've
got you engaged and if it wasn't that
maybe it was human labor issues and
slaughterhouses where the immigrants are
poorly treated and that those are the
only ones working in the slaughterhouse
and terrible other people won't
volunteer for that and it's very abusive
system and we should slow down the speed
of the slaughterhouse and we should take
better care of the work
for some people that gets their
attention so what I learned in this
class was of all the one hour lectures I
can get give on insulin or antioxidants
or microbiome or whatever
if it doesn't change or die if I had
these other things in my tool chest
and I brought them in
if they choose to follow animal rights
and Welfare or climate change or human
labor abuses they would be eating the
way I wanted them to the first time it's
sort of they are discovering the what's
animating a person and using that
enthusiasm as a trojan horse to bring in
this stuff about nutrition and it's
aligned it's actually surprisingly what
when when you see what they're doing
after they hear about these issues
they're eating more plant Foods they're
eating less fast food they're eating
less meat they're cooking more on their
own they're going to the farmers market
they're eating fresh food they're eating
less Ultra processed food
it's just getting at them another way
and just finding what what are their hot
buttons to motivate them to make a
change and sustain it
uh and the last one there is
deliciousness where we're sort of
working with chefs now we're doing this
protein flip getting to eat more plants
and say you
um unapologetically delicious is a very
important term to me because it reminds
me I don't know how much it resonates
with everybody else but it came from
Greg Drescher at The Culinary Institute
of America and as soon as he said I
thought
you're right I have been apologizing I
know how metabolism works and I've been
saying I know you want to have the steak
or the cookie I have some cardboard for
you
cardboard is going to lower your
cholesterol and my face scrunches up and
I say I'm sorry that you're giving up on
taste to have cardboard and Greg
Drescher looked at me and said why are
you apologizing why don't you say that
this is kick-ass global fusion of
flavors this plant-based mouth-watering
relentlessly delicious dish that we have
created by putting Moroccan spices on
this Heritage Grain topped in seared
vegetables or this so that you're
salivating listening to and you're not
apologizing anymore
you're saying this is the Taste is
amazing so we've been leading with taste
which is not that hard to do working
with chefs and having Health in the
environment in the back pocket and a
couple of other issues and so I I think
of it as stealth nutrition not deceit
just recognizing how many values a
person brings to the table when they're
thinking do I choose a or b
I think of it as seamless nutrition okay
you know taking like removing that
negative kind of connotation all
together the seamlessness part being the
connection between the animating Force
within an individual and the better food
choice but also deploying those chefs in
the right way to move the most number of
people in other words by employing them
at institutions that are serving lots of
people three times a day because for
many people students and in our
Workforce that's where they're getting
their food yeah and if you can elevate
the quality of food that's being offered
at those institutions you're making a
much much bigger Dent than trying to
convince people one-on-one or you know
that they should it's like it's that
blue Zone's idea of you have to make the
healthier choice that the one that's
within Arm's Reach and the more
convenient choice if you can go Step
Beyond that we actually have to grow and
raise different food to be able to do
that
if institutions start ordering that food
a farmer would be inclined to change you
really want me to change my crop I need
to make a living I'm not sure if there
would be a demand oh my God the
universities are asking for this the
work sites are asking for this the the
institutional food settings are asking
for this change I can see the demand I'm
going to change what I'm growing and
respond that way and the more that's
available in the chef's offer to the
students in the worksite folks and they
respond positively
the more they'll order it again right
but you're making it sound a lot easier
than I'm sure that it is when you start
talking about school lunch and you know
hospital food service I mean there's
massive corporations bureaucracies
lobbying efforts like this is a you know
there's a lot of people who've tried to
solve this problem and have walked away
you know sort of but well beaten here so
there's a second class I teach now
called healthy and sustainable Food
Systems and in that class I bring in a
speaker from a hospital from a
University from Google for a work site
from a food bank from a K-12 School food
service director and when the students
sign up for the class they think this is
all theoretical and the people I bring
in have made those changes in their
orders and the students are blown away
like this isn't theoretical you actually
you changed what you order you did that
you don't offer that anymore you focus
on that you emphasize why did you do
that and it's working
so I would say there is movement in that
direction in institutional food which is
why I want everybody to hug a chef
because part of this is
bringing the chefs in as partners
in this movement because taste is so
important here and taking advantage of
their skill set
to help move this forward they've been
fabulous partners for me they're my most
intriguing new partners in research is
bringing in a chef yeah that's cool and
I know you've done a bunch of stuff with
Google yeah not regard too
super fun interesting Yeah final thing
uh and I I asked this question
frequently with with people of your
credentials and caliber which is if you
woke up
tomorrow morning in a parallel universe
and found yourself to be the Surgeon
General of the United States what is
first order of business like how are you
tackling the problems that we Face from
a nutrition perspective and and what are
the changes regulatory policy wise
legislative just or otherwise that you
would be interested in pushing forward
yep look everything we've talked about
today but a focus on beans beans are
so undervalued and underappreciated so
thinking about all the things that we
talk about and eating better one of the
things that often gets left out is
people with food insecurity or nutrition
insecurity like who has the resources
for this food how can it be culturally
appropriate
there are so many kinds of beans we got
lentils we got dolls pulses uh chickpeas
hummus think of how many amazing
bean-based dishes there are and how
inexpensive dried beans are and all you
got to do is soak them overnight or even
canned beans are pretty expensive super
nutritious high fiber the highest of any
kind of plant food of protein so if you
are trying to displace some of those
animal-based Foods
beans are the obvious answer and it is
embarrassing how few beans Americans eat
compared to the rest of the world and
the other food groups so if I were to do
anything
I do want to focus on what we said in
the beginning more vegetables more Whole
Foods less added sugar lesser fine
grains
but almost separate than that
beans there's a woman in Liz Carlisle
who wrote Amazing book called The lentil
underground and it is a really fun thing
about Trader Joe's partnering with the
lentil farmers and finding a way to
package lentils that was sort of just
consumer friendly and it elevated lentil
farmers at least for a while I don't
know where it is today
and it was one of these structural
issues of oh wow lentils actually cook
more quickly than the other beans
they're quite versatile
so I mean among the bean family lentils
would be a great example but what could
oh how easy is it to make hummus at home
I my kid I had some raw veggies at the
table and my kids said I would eat these
if there was any hummus but there isn't
and I got up from the dinner table and I
got my food processor out I had hummus
on the table in three minutes I chucked
in garbanzo is an olive oil and you know
some tahini that I had there and some
lemon and some what is it uh
super fast I just blended it up and kid
ate the vegetables with the hummus and
it was super delicious so yeah if I was
Czar for the day you'd be the bean guy
you're the bean Surgeon General I think
I would be the bean Surgeon General
because it's so versatile
and everything we talked about the the
lentil thing with Trader Joe's is that
part of like because they offer they're
the only place I've been where you can
buy cooked lentils in like a shrink
wrapped thing they're already cooked
yeah and I buy those all the time
because they make for a great snack you
just crack them open into a bowl and put
some whatever hot sauce on it or just
eat them the way that they are right and
it's
super cheap and right Trader Joe's has
done a marvelous job of making things
convenient and relatively inexpensive so
that model if we could build on that
model of making some very simple Foods
more accessible
um yeah and even sort of like chopping
and freezing the veggies so a bunch of
people think oh frozen vegetables I want
fresh
frozen veggies are pretty good if you
imagine all the miles the fresh stuff
had to travel and how to lock in the
nutrients right yes there was versus no
I froze it on site it's more shelf
stable now although you do have to have
refrigeration yeah I would I would try
to take advantage of some things like
that that everyone could enjoy and you'd
done sort of partial prep so because
people also fear inconvenience in the
U.S and so it needs to be low cost tasty
and convenient and I think there's a lot
of room for movement there
um
so you get this book that you're working
on it's coming out when sometime next
year sometime next year yeah yeah and
beyond that what are you working on
right now or what's got you excited what
is the study that you want to be
performing or that you want to see put
into action yeah so if it's okay the two
that are most exciting right now is one
with pregnant women and the microbiome
so we're getting for second and third
trimester
moms are getting randomly assigned to
have more fiber or more fermented food
or both or neither so there's four arms
130 pregnant women
and we monitor their microbiome during
pregnancy and then we wait for the birth
and one month in we measure the kid's
microbiome and that's our main outcome
but we continue to follow the kid for
years after that we're trying to learn
how the mom could optimize for maternal
microbiome
in a way that she passes it off to her
kit so what is the lasting effect of
that over time in the child and well how
does how persistent so we've got these
dietary changes but we're also facing
gestational diabetes C-section versus
vaginal birth breastfeeding versus not
what foods they wean their kids on so
we're trying to sort of open the door on
this transmission of optimizing maternal
microbiome that gets to the kid because
what we find is whatever you got from
your mom a lot of that sticks with you
right forever so that one's pretty fun
we're uh is that with the sonnenbergs
yeah so we've got 120 women now we just
need 10 more women we already have 70
babies born so that one's super fun
the other more interesting one is one
along the lines of one of the last
things about food security so in the
fall of 2022 the White House had a
conference first one of this magnitude
in 56 years
on Hunger nutrition and health and in
that
American Heart Association and the
Rockefeller Institute pledged 250
million dollars to address food as
medicine or food as medicine depending
on which way you want to call it the
idea being
ensures pay a lot of money for covering
drugs
would it be worthwhile for insurers to
cover meals
and there's act so food working has met
they're they're covering meals like they
would cover a drug for somebody with
diabetes or heart disease or cancer or
something so there are a bunch of small
short-term studies out there that aren't
very appropriate for proving this
concept would work
so American Heart and Rockefeller say
okay how about 250 million dollars over
years let's design this thing let's take
people with food insecurity who classify
as having food insecurity
and have these conditions
and see if we can do there's a couple
things you can do what's called
medically tailored meals or medically
tailored groceries or produce
prescriptions there's a couple different
ways you could do it how could we help
these people eat a better diet and not
go on drugs and prevent disease and
could we get insurers to cover this
isn't there a cost benefit to that so to
me that is a long overdue issue that we
could be helping with
that would be a massive Watershed
breakthrough yeah just to burst the seal
on insurance coverage of food the broken
healthcare system which is really not a
Health Care System it's a sick care
system it's only focused on people who
are already sick you need to dial it
back and prevent it and diet
such a huge under appreciated
underutilized factor for preventing
disease
I think that's a great place to stop it
for today we didn't even get into uh
much of the microbiome stuff in detail
but that gives me an excuse to get you
back here okay to talk about all the
fascinating emergent work that's
happening there as well as these
advances in in the world of personalized
nutrition I know you're on the
scientific Advisory Board of Zoe yeah
Zoe being the personalized nutrition
company that was co-founded by Tim
Spector founded who was recently a guest
here and of course Dr Dr B will
bolsowitz yeah been on the show a couple
times so I think there's a lot of really
interesting things that that company is
doing and the caliber of of individuals
who are involved with it I think is
pretty interesting and compelling so I I
look forward to learning more about
what's coming out of that meeting of the
minds and and all of this microbiome
stuff as well yeah very excited and
super happy that you're promoting this
kind of thing because it the field is
moving and I think you're really helping
people stay on top of it yeah well
thanks for coming and sharing today that
was really eye-opening and and fantastic
and uh it only scratches the surface so
yes lots more to talk about uh so I
appreciate you please keep doing all the
work that you're doing if there's
anything I can do to help you please
reach out and in the meantime if people
want to connect uh with you beyond this
conversation where do you typically
direct them you've got a Twitter and all
that kind of stuff but is there
somewhere I'll put links in the show
notes to All the studies that we talked
about Etc but
um yep so we have a lot of our studies
and a bunch of videos that you can get
to uh so our website you can go to Just
nutrition.stanford.edu it'll actually
send you somewhere else but that's
easier to remember
nutrition.stanford.edu it's just past
studies current studies we've held a
whole series of food Summits on campus
we have tons of videos about food
Summits where we've brought people in
from all seven schools in Stanford to
give us their take on food and so you
did this Camp do you are you still doing
the camp so this is that 12th or 13th
year of farm camp where I get Stanford
undergrads to be counselors on an 11
acre organic farm on the grounds of a
middle school in Sunnyvale California it
had been a high school demographics
changed and they went to a middle school
where they didn't need the baseball
football or soccer field they converted
it into an 11 acre organic farm and we
have a camp and the kids come and it's
lunch time you say what should we have
for lunch should we Slaughter some
animals no there's no animals around
let's pick veggies and then we say oh
let's eat raw veggies no let's let's
cook them we have stos and we have pots
and pans and we hand kids knives and
they say wow my mom and dad don't give
me knives to cut things up with my mom
and dad doesn't let me play with fire
and they saute veggies and they pick
fresh herbs and they it's a stealth
nutrition way of just this the stuff
part is just let's get them engaged in
tending them harvesting them chopping
them seasoning them and oh how about
that they want to eat it after you did
all that work you told me about a kid
who was pre-med at Stanford who was on
the track to becoming a plastic surgeon
yep and he as a result of this
experience course corrected was he a
counselor or did he go to the other
Summit he was a council counselor at the
camp he came and uh he loved it so much
he wasn't supposed to so I hope that
person isn't listening but he would stay
overnight and sleep on the farm he like
changed his life and he became a farmer
instead of a physician it's amazing and
he's been going around the country
working in different Farms was a
wrestler wanted a BMW not anymore he
plays guitar at the farm and and grows
turned him into a hippie yep pretty fun
awesome all right well thank you my
friend come back again soon I appreciate
you I'd love to thanks for having me
that was really fun conversation peace
what peace out